welcome everybody to the final
speed chess championship grand prix
i'm grand master robert hess and i'm going to
bring you the call today it is our typical you
know title tuesday speeches championship grand
reaction the format as we will remind you is
what's in every tuesday three minute plus one
second increment time control it is a ten round
swiss tournament the top eight finishers advance
to the knockout bracket and there's a lot of prize
money at stake each week a thousand dollar first
place prize it's no surprise that hikaru nakamura
has won the lion's share of these events but
other people have done quite well thus far
in their attempt to qualify for the speed chess
championship and you can see all the way down
uh the quarterfinals make 100 top female
player and the top streamer also get 100
and to remind everybody about the scoring system
because this is a qualifier for the main speeches
championship the base points are their swiss score
out of 10 it's whatever you scored in those 10
rounds then if you win the knockout you get 12
bonus points and that we'll talk more about that
because it's going to play a very important role
as we will have four qualifiers making their way
into the speed chest chamber you see on the
graphic in front of you the bottom right hand side
there four players from the sec grand prix will
make their way the speeches championship there
was the super swiss which vladimir feroceaev
took a spot and there's the jscc which nihal
tsarnaev won and later we will have the speed
chess championship invitational but i mentioned
vladimir putin and that's particularly important
because if you look at the standings on the screen
in front of you you will see that vladimir putin
is in third place in the sccgp hikar nakamura is
in first but he is the reigning speeches champion
speed chess championship champion or can i just
say speeches champion i don't know but you know
what i'm talking about hikaru did win that so
he already is qualified federsev qualified by
virtue of finishing second to hikaru in the
super swiss so that leaves four spots up for grabs
artemyev looks like he's locked himself up a spot
no surprise there he is one of the best players on
this planet then you have nordivec abducitarov who
fell short in the jscc but has been a mainstay
of the knockout brackets here in the speeches
champion grand prix series then you have parham
maksudu right behind nordivec he looks like he is
in good shape to qualify and then that's where
it gets tricky hike marti rosian would be the
fourth qualifier had we not had one more speeches
championship grand prix and players like alireza
faruja who okay let's be real i'll get an invite
whether or not he qualifies by virtue of this
uh grand prix you have maxim chigayov maxime
vashiola grav and we also have tuamenlei the
wonderful international master from vietnam
wonderful time they all have a chance because you
get their base points from the swiss then you get
bonus points in the knockout which means that all
of these players are within striking distance and
well i would say without further ado we will have
uh the action but we still have a minute so let's
talk about some of the players in the field today
hikaru of course taking part we have uh vladimir
ferrissev that is big fish 1995. he really gave
hikar all he could handle in the super swiss
that's the name that you'll want to keep an eye on
there's arjun aragasi and the number three
seed then there's nuribeck abuse he's going
to lock up his spot he'll make his way to speeches
championship proper and number five that's one of
the players we're going to keep an eye on today is
the beast from lyon that is maxime of shayla grav
we mentioned that he is on the outside looking in
okay we also figure that he probably will get an
invitation regardless i don't know the invites
but he is maxine vashila grub after all he's a
top 10 player in the world and it doesn't really
feel like a speechless championship without his
participation but he could qualify directly
by taking the fourth spot away from a player
like hayek martirosian i do not see hike's name
here on the listed entrance for today's sec gp
so that is going to be an interesting
storyline going forward uh right behind
maxime is fair chess on youtube that is dimitri
on draken a super strong russian grandmaster he
is a super grand master he's also a speed chess
specialist if you will so it's nice to be 2700
plus feed a classical and still be considered a
speed chess specialist we have le quang liam there
behind him giga cooperative he's strong
georgian grand master ronin said moani
parham well we said he's number three and
he will lock up his spot for qualification
there's um martinez from peru jaspham we have
azeri chest which is the one and only chakra mama
jarov msb2 that is matthias bluebaum from germany
alexander zubov and then we have an international
master from uh peru ronaldo terry lujan and just
by doing these events so much i can just look at a
username and i know exactly who that participant
is um it's just you get familiar with these
people week in and week out and i've had the
pleasure and privilege of playing many of them
myself so we do have liftoff let us start at the
top because why not we'll start with hikaru's
game he has the black pieces in the opening round
taking on a 2500 player so no easy matches in the
speeches championship grand prix every single
round we'll see a super grandmaster like a car
take on a very strong blitz player and here hikaru
adopts the setup of a karo khan that looks like
it's mixed with an alien defense and you have
these double f pawns which don't look very good
at some point you do play f5 try to open up this
bishop but look at the car and go he is just
lightning quick knows what he wants play a4 put
this bishop on e6 take over the diagonal so if
i were white i'd probably a3 to keep my bishop
on this diagonal as even though it's not the end
of the world for the bishop to get kicked to c2
what is that bishop doing there and he actually
voluntarily plays it which surprises me because
it's staring to a brick wall of a pawn structure
with uh the f7 g6 h7 configuration so i like this
opening for hikar i think he has obtained a very
good position one that he feels comfortable with
and that he should just play without real risk
because the bishop on c2 now feels quite misplaced
and this bishop comes right to e6 in a moment's
notice taking over important light squares here
from e6 all the way to c4 uh it looks like white
is thinking in this game we'll move on over to
some others for now just to see what's going on
okay b3 doesn't actually attack anything by the
way because the knight does protect a4 so let's
keep on moving let's go to peters fiddler why not
we love ourselves some peter's fiddler action in
the sec gp and his opponent and national master
has his bishop on g4 and more importantly now the
bishop on b6 that's an open diagonal and so white
is going to have difficulty castling here i think
that peter would like to replace this bishop with
his knight because if you can envision the knight
on c4 it attacks the queen and attacks the bishop
but that's very hard to accomplish especially with
let's put this queen in green because it's a good
piece and the bishop on f5 you are staring down
the center of the board so it's more likely a
knight is going to go to the e4 square which
is just going to be a good move and developing
move and clogging the center here but for the
time being white's king stuck in the center that
does leave me a bit nervous about peter's chances
but he is peter svidler the eight-time russian
champion the commentator extraordinaire and
a friend of mine i have faith in his ability to
handle a position like this and g4 g4 almost made
me knock my own glasses off because you don't
expect a move like g4 but can he go after this
bishop and he does so he's trying to go h5 right
now no knight e4 first i guess h5 can happen in
the near future you can also play g5 use this pawn
h6 as a hook to pry open the king's side so peter
is i see the bar just jumping up in his favor
it does look like quite a nice position now i
wasn't expecting g4 but he is more familiar with
these positions than i am and is it time for g5
that's the the answer is clearly yes definitively
yes and i would not be happy on the black side of
this position no no no no the king is about
to be opened uh you can put a rook on g1 to
use the g file i see the bar continuing to just
go crazy over here you can probably take this
uh bishop on h7 if need be amongst other moves
i mean the position is looking so so good here
and oh playing g6 that doesn't look good
that can't be good freeze up control over the
f6 square as well and okay if i can take you
on g7 and then swing over the h file looks like
there could be just mates maybe take on d5 bring
the rook off the last rank and then take me on g7
instead because queen issue first to take on g7
next and in comes this queen let's say on this
one to the end of the game because we may see just
see a resignation or a checkmate in the next few
turns and svidler out to a blazing hot start down
the age file look at these pieces lined up here
and i like that he didn't rush to take on g7 i
was advocating for that move it almost certainly
was a good decision but there are times where you
can't take a decision like that back and it could
backfire so instead he puts his queen and rook on
the opening h file he will take on g7 and that's
just going to be a very swift victory for him if
you play f6 well you're walking into a pin but
you're also allowing me to capture on g7 anyway
because i'm opening the h file queen takes me by
knight e6 with the oh gosh it's a cruncher look
at the fork here hitting the queen and both rooks
well you can't survive this no no way knight
takes f8 actually wins a piece because if the
rook takes an f8 you lose this knight on d5 if
okay it takes this way because f6 is hanging also
wins a piece everything wins that's the benefit
of having this position first fiddler i was
and there's a resignation i was saying that
taking here works because you take with the
rook you lose the knight directly if you take with
the king instead you lose this bishop on h7 so
all roads were victorious for svidler he
takes down his opponent let's move on over to
maxime vashila grav the beast from leon with the
black pieces here this is actually quite a complex
a rich position where black is down two pawns but
look at these open lines here for black's pieces
this could amount to a huge attack and wipe down
to 18.9 seconds however the two extra pawns if
you're not careful they can make their presence
felt with a series of trades so queen h extract
the king is going to go to e7 but watch out for
knight f5 check because the point is that this
pawn is needed to protect the bishop the king
drops to h1 i'm already looking for putting a
piece of some sort on d6 and going rook h8 but
that seems hard to accomplish queen takes on f6
so if i could get your bishop to move that would
be a checkmate but he drops his bishop back to e7
where's his queen going queen f4 perhaps all
right and bishop g5 is possible but you may
walk into a pin because the rook on jeet is not
defended so you'd have to walk your king up to
keep it defended or to make a difference i should
say so knight p5 is tempting to me at some point
just to bring this knight into some of these
dark squares and get after this king on the
eight that's not a very safe king so in the very
first game it looks like maxine he's trying to
fend off his opponent uh an armenian player
almost 2500 and knight f5 is always going to be
tempting but not quite yet your queen is hanging
so queen e5 played first now knight f5 is serious
the e pawn is pinned because otherwise you take
this bishop on e7 there will be ideas of getting
this bishop on d5 so rook g5 played in queen v8
check then rook back to c8 okay so hanging on
for now is maxime and two seconds once barely
got the move off 92 barely in time there
and this knight can re-route to f4 to get after
this pin bishop that looks like one of the ideas
here rook c8 played the queen has to retreat and
barely got that move of 2.4 seconds left this is
getting close with bishop c5 less queen f6 you
won't allow that queen to get after the f7 pawn
so that would be a mistake and it feels like the
movie you want to play is this bishop move but not
in time so king e8 played knight f4 i expect okay
one maybe they move with 0.1 seconds just flagged
the guy queen c4 queen aj check king here knight
takes d5 was possible and queen a1 rerounding the
queen to come over to a7 rook takes g3 what a move
rook hey check oh the queen could take it oh young
he hung it but he didn't see it oh my gosh she got
lucky there and now there must be some tactics by
taking on h3 so like queen to c6 or queen b3 i was
looking at trying to take on h3 on f3 so bishop's
seven queen d4 2.4 seconds left still for white
queen g oh queen g a check that's it that's it
and maxine wins on time in a position where his
opponent can check him and win the rook oh my gosh
now that is the type of finish that we love to see
in the sec gp because queen ga check says thank
you for your rook you're not actually checking me
kingdom i don't know king d7 i guess to try to be
safer but after here queen g3 the king can just
go to g1 and that's only one check my king can
start escaping out that way so that was a missed
shot by white maxine moves on he wins the game and
he keeps his chances of qualifying from this alive
so many more games to go let's tune in to this one
it is a bishop of same color ending which is bad
news for the defensive side and that's vladimir on
ashoka very strong ukrainian grand master he looks
like he's going down to his opponent here unless
he can get enough counter play and he loses on
time so no counter play for him that's just a
loss on the clock let's keep on going this is
gawain jones has how many queens two queens i
think that's enough and queen e5 check take my
queen i take yours let me simplify this into an
easily winning position where it's one extra queen
still but now white has no more pieces left and
okay wild tricks going for some tricks but rook f7
check okay work up six majors happening here good
game going jones too strong enough to convert that
one and we're getting down to the finish line here
okay this is a pawn that are you going to be able
to get it kg4 there are some opportunities to draw
positions like this but knight f4 is met by rook
to g8 check which means that white would win and
king f6 knight uh oh knight h5 knight back and
then you go knight h5 and the knight back tower
just don't take the pawn because as soon as you
take the pawn the king will come to g6 and take
advantage of the pin knight wait they're just
repeating so king of seven do not take the pawn
do not take this pawn because the king g6 happens
but this is going to be a draw wow what a hold
that is one of those cool rook h5 it's really
one of those cool end games that you don't get
to see all the time where even though white
is an exchange up and with an extra pawn
there's no way to make progress as this knight
goes back and forth and if this knight comes with
a check and the king comes to e5 you still do not
take this pawn taking the pawn whilst king to f5
and then the king has to go away from the knights
you just have to be careful about your timing
and we are in the second round hikaru
nakamura gets the white pieces here
so he is going to try to make it two out of two
a perfect score and thanks to everybody who's
tuning in really appreciate it um here we go
hikaru in the second game uh let's uh stay away
from the car for now because we will obviously
look at way more hikaru later in this event we
sort of anticipate most often that he will be
making his way to the knockout stages just because
he's that good and let me uh pull ups maybe some
of our streamers because we do have uh plenty of
our streamers taking part in this so let me find
one for us to follow let's uh let's go to chelsea
monaco's game because it is the second round of
action here um she has drawn her first game which
almost certainly would have been upset and now
she is playing playing somebody nearly 2 700. so
we have uh her stream like we can pull it up and
well right now white has more control over the
board look at these pawns advanced everywhere and
we see her calculating right now i like this setup
that's a i like the pawn the chess.com background
it uh looks pretty clean and her position
is a bit of a struggle but she is
a capable player that's for sure
and she'll try to combat her opponent's aggressive
pawn pushes and try to keep the position
locked up and i think that's her best chances
if the position remains locked up and white
isn't time to crash through that gives her enough
time here to reroute her pieces to
reorganize but it still looks pretty bad
so i think that her position isn't so great
here and that's why she's sitting and thinking
so let's uh maybe go out
to another streamer we have
badur jibawa taking part in this tournament see
him there and baidura is such a fun player he's
playing entertaining games no matter who
his opponent is he could play magus carlson
he could be playing against me he could be
playing against a 1200 you know that his
games are going to be a lot of fun and in
this one look at him drawing arrows for us
talking about that bishop on f4 moving in both
directions he's let's look out for the h6 pawn
because that queen on g3 does pin the pawn on
g7 so bishop takes h6 could be the next move
and he's still calculating where to move his
king he wants to make sure he does not drop
a pawn especially one in front of his king
side that would be important and i can only
imagine what he's saying i do like his streaming
setup as well by doris just he's a funny guy
but okay he uh we'll leave him to figure that
out we'll come back in with our buddy vladimir
ferrosev because he has just played a very
interesting move g5 in what looked like a calm
innocuous position he plays g5 trying to open up
the king side as his opponent has a really solid
foundation here look at white's pawn structure
safe and sound we have a pawn chain going to
d4 we have a semi-open e file the semi-open c file
doesn't really amount to anything just yet so i do
prefer a white's position here but we'll see how
federal state handles this and well while we're
talking about streamers we remiss not to include
the biggest chess streamer not named ludwig that
is hikaru nakamura and we see a car trying to
figure out this position from the white side
he is a pawn ahead and black is trying to
close down the position but here comes b5
for hikaru just trying to rush that pawn up and
create a past fun of his own so even if it costs
him a pawn it may still be worth it and i like
his dual cam setup there so you can see hikaru
very directly from in front of him but also a side
cam just checking out his monitor and he's been
a big advocate of this setup to ensure that there
is no fair play violations that way you can see
the screen you can see the player um i'm a fan of
the setup and of course a fan of hikaru because
he is just an absolutely brilliant chess player
and he is taking the streaming world by storm
tsm mccarron excuse me i misspoke and look at him
go he is breaking through there on the queen's
side so his opponent didn't actually capture him
b5 and i think he made a wise choice he's trying
to lock up the position so if hikar for some
reason played the move a5 that would probably
be a mistake because the white king should try
to get to a5 like that's one of the ideas but
he's playing on both sides of the board principle
of two weaknesses h5 rook to g1 you can go from
flank to flank and this e pawn is also a pass pawn
so there's no way for black to close this position
down that's what he wants to do is put a piece on
b7 put it put rook on b7 put a king on e6 and say
you can't make any progress but a car was just
claiming yes i can here comes the h-bomb that's
take it if you want i'm jettisoning that pawn and
i'm trying to open up another flank of attack and
here comes the rook which means that white is
making progress and in fact black just resigned
that's a knot of respect to an elite player and
a card nakamura goes to two and up so let's go to
alina kashunskaya she took part in the i'm not
gm speeches championship she was a finalist
she unfortunately for her lost
in the finals to john bartholomew
a fan favorite and what's going on here looks
like there's trouble down the c in the d
lines there could be a checkmate for black if
white is not careful but somehow all of these
important squares are under white's control so
there is no mate yet and said min goes right after
this knight on b6 and queen takes b4 does not
work i was mentioning i need to watch out for
a check down here so bishop takes b5 and white
does have two pieces for the rook so after
eight takes b5 if the queen takes b4 happened
you could take on b6 but you're only getting
the two pieces back for your rook and bishop c5
now b6 is hanging behind that b5 is hanging but
look at this at the end of the day you take c5
i take b5 and now it's in exchange up for black
nice transition white does have an extra pawn for
that exchange so if she can stabilize her forces
on the queen side perhaps get this pawn to b4 it's
not going to be so easy for black to make progress
here and i like the move b4 and the point is that
if we trade rooks how are you going to go after my
pawns i think that you have enough time to play f6
king f7 and rook h8 in the event of an exchange of
rooks and how do you exchange rooks you could have
started with rook to d2 instead he's just going to
go king f7 and he leaves this open rook h8 and
once rookie shade happens you play g5 you need
to actually create problems for your opponent and
he actually has accomplished just that although
allowing the pawn to go to b6 feels a little bit
like a mistake wait rook takes v6 a free pawn
i guess it wasn't dragging the pawn results
in a simple win of the pawn and here he goes
he is up in a clean exchange he can bring his
king in and that should be the end of the game so
yeah this is going after this pawn white is
going to try her best to hang on here but now
f5 is even possible that's what you want to do
is take over the light squares your king can
infiltrate in light squares and that's a not a
very good bishop trying to hold it off and he's
going to bring his king to h5 and then white will
be in swan can't keep the king on h3 forever and
then comes the kingdom g4 f4 h4 one of them both
of them are falling and that's a win for black so
let's keep on going down the list of games here we
have plenty remaining why don't we go to this game
here jostling with the white pieces it shall be a
win for him look at that bishop d4 that is just a
a little precision there take my bishop that way
my pawn goes free and i don't have to give you
my pawn so i'm going to play h5 if oh actually
h5 could backfire if you're not careful so what
uh black is hoping for is to trade off some pawns
and win the well okay it's irrelevant now because
here comes this pass pawn that
was just very fine technique
by grandmaster martinez from peru let's keep on
going down the list so many games still underway
it's what happens when there's a tournament
of nearly 600 players uh why don't we go oh
there are two past pawns but there's a good bishop
covering these this diagonal so check can i start
pushing my a pawn i don't think you're in time
to do that the rook can always swing to a8
and now you can just get a queen uh-oh be
careful if you move the bishop f7 happens
so that was important with king e6 where he
win the rook and now white is an exchange ahead
this is a drawn position rook against bishop
but just bear kings remaining besides those
pieces that is a draw but not always easy
to accomplish when you're in time trouble
so i think this one shall be a draw we'll see
if uh there will be a hold here and i just saw
another result it looks like the beast from leon
maxine virtually was held to a draw in his game
so we'll he'll need to bounce back and score a
lot of points can't afford too many splits in this
one oh king is in the corner watch out for that
this is i hold because if the bishop comes to h7
and the rook's on the age file there's a stalemate
so bishop you would love to just keep the rook as
a stamina exactly what i'm saying normally if you
were on a different line you would be able to push
the king but there's no space off the side of the
board right there's the boundary so that's just a
stalemate the king on f7 doesn't help you win the
piece it just actually helps create the snail mate
all right so let's keep on going here
we have probably a few games remaining
we have a completely winning rook end game
up two pawns is white and plenty of time
15 seconds no big deal just uh cruising so
a two and a half score is liam brolic and
you bring your king in push the pawns c5
now yikes and that's just a resignation
and i believe that was our final game of the
round let me check no we actually have one more
oh gosh rook and bishop against rook now that's
a pain to hold in any time control but especially
blitz i do think that white very likely will win
this game the king is already in the corner here
nope rook takes bishop as soon as i say that
rotates bishop the rook oh misses it you could
just take in that bishop because the rook would
have been able to block on h5 now rookie six check
your king has to go back up to h5 and this
is going to be no fun you can't go king h6
rook comes here to block on h6 in the case of
rook h7 check so rook and bishop vs rook it
strikes again king h6 you want to bring the king
to g7 good idea king could come right back to uh
h5's necessary watch out ooh the king is close
to being instead th7 is possible nope that's the
wrong way that's wrong you have to know that
you can you have to walk into the discovery
because the king and rook are so close together
there's no discovery against it and here it comes
yeah this is a win it's a win oh boy oh boy you
need to know your rookie bishop vs rook end game
is very difficult i was saying that in the duress
of time trouble but you have to know what you can
get away with and after oh new game started okay
don't have enough time to show everybody the ins
and outs of the rook ambition versus rook but
learn that end game especially if you're a more
advanced player this will be happening in your
games more often so we have the chess warrior
that is rudy beckham bruce taurev but let's take
a moment and give a shout out to anna crumling
who is taking part in this tournament very popular
streamer always entertaining i've commentated with
her before she's uh just such a good person always
always in an upbeat mood honestly so fun to watch
her channel do check it out and we do have many
many streamers taking part we have andrew tang
always on cloud nine these days he is playing in
this one looks like he's at a perfect 2-0 score
so give the penguin gm one the penguin gm
one i just want to call him the penguin gm
but i know there's a numeral i'm not a numeral
just a number in his name so it's hard to say
just give the penguin some love he deserves
it and he is signed to a big esports work so
uh yeah let's uh
keep on going here as we continue looking at this
game between nordibekker musatarov and wannabe
2700 and we see that white has this knight on
e5 protected by a stonewall like structure of
d4 and f4 pawns but as is typical here
the issue is the e4 square is available
to block this knight comes to d6 and that
comes into e4 and black can eventually play
pawn to f6 in a way that white cannot because
white has advanced these pawns to d4 and f4
which leaves the e4 square as a vulnerable spot
so black can push upon four once the knight
was at the way white cannot push upon back to
cover e4 so that's the advantage i would give
to black in this position but white is still very
solid so even if you get one square the e4 square
you still have a lot to prove after that so uh
not the most interesting of games just yet we will
probably see more of nerdy beck as time goes
on but let us uh move on to some other games
i always like to hop around as much as i can so
we'll go here to seo robert i did not pick this
game because the person is robert in their handle
but i did see lamlay taking part and even though
black's pawn structure is double this is actually
an advantage for black and you could think about
it what happens when you double pawns it means
that there is an open line for your pieces
because there would have been a d pawn it captured
on c5 or on c6 wherever it captured like them
uh actually let me look at this scoresheet to
see where it did capture because i would say
likely on c6 if this were from the spanish but
now i see took on c5 directly so watch out here
oh gosh this is just a huge problem i think that
white's already toast this these light squares
knight f3 check you might have to play e4 or
knight d5 but can i just take it and he does
because after queen takes e4 now i take your pawn
e4 that's a big issue you have to try to block me
from getting on the diagonal but i just take on e4
and the point is that your rook on d2 is hanging
so this rook we're on d1 this wouldn't work out
quite as nicely for black but because the rook
is on d2 it's left under attack e4 i take
it and i can move my knight back or if you
take me back on e4 and win your rook on d2 and
black has scooped off two pawns for his troubles
temporary sacrifice netting material so if not
e4 okay now knight h3 and queen each one's mate
gosh i'm sorry seo robert that wasn't good that
was good you need to turn yourself more to ceo
robert and show lamela who's boss let's go circuit
karjakin what did i just turn into here karjakin
with the white pieces it is his move the king just
went no what okay e5 was by c the e seven square
was highlighted and i was like well what just
happened but e7 e5 so this stems from some kind of
bizarre queen e5 f6 giving up the c5 pawn and
then playing e5 so black is trying to finish
the development in castle and white is trying to
claim hey your pawn structure is bad i have more
development than you so i should be doing well but
i think that black could even consider castling by
hand with bishop e6 king f7 and then bring this
rook into the game queen c6 played instead and
okay black has some dark square potential
issues but does have the bishop pair
now this looks very pleasant for black i like it
i like it here what's up to everybody who's tuning
in i see you trying to do my best to cover all the
action but i'll keep an eye on the chat to make
sure that everyone's having a good time and this
is a problem for sergey i think bishop d5
this knight is now under attack if bishop
e7 i'm going to just take back on e7 and claim my
bishop is great and here 96 check i think king e6
what is sergey walking into here what does he see
that i don't because king e6 is such a natural
move applying pressure and not just the knight
but the bishop behind the knight so knight b7
looks forced i would say otherwise
you know in 94 i just take you
so knight b7 so this was a really bad
transition for sergey but his knight
does extricate itself to the c5 square so instead
we're going to opposite bishops the bishop goes
back to e3 but is a2 hanging that's the question
that i've been asking myself for a while
at what point can black just say let me take
this pawn because white typically has b3 to shut
that bishop out and that will be the case here
as well but he goes rook a5 that's way smarter
way way smart just going right for the a2 pawn
not having to worry about the bishop getting
caught there because the rook will land on a2
instead and if you play a3 doesn't change much i
just take you on a3 black wins a pawn white still
has good chances to hold by virtue of having the
opposite colored bishops as is typical in obstacle
bishop positions many of these end games when
liquidation occurs can still be held but i think
that black is in the driver's seat for sure um
let's see okay we'll stay here for
a bit just because i'm curious about
white's counter play and it is circuit karjakin i
mentioned he was on the outside looking in if he
does very well makes to the knockout
and score some bonus points he could
find himself as a top four finisher in the sec
gp he can overtake a player like martirosian
but he needs to prove himself here and right
now not looking so great in this particular
game he is up a little bit on the clock but he
needs to find his way here and right now he's
spending a lot of time is he going to play f3 to
kick this bishop is he going to throw his rook
into d6 he plays g4 trying to stop the king from
getting to f5 but that also makes a bishop f3 and
oh oh that pawn is now a weakness
there's going to be some back rank
issues with checkmating nets so he's giving
himself the g3 square i'm not sure i'm buying
it h5 played if i take you just take with
the bishop that way you don't drop his g7
but wait bishop with eight then there's rook
a7 very important move rook a7 and a whole
what he gives up the pawn just plays
bishop e2 interesting choice there
okay so bishop f3 back does it gives up the c6
pawn as well i don't think that circus in any
danger anymore he's definitely not going to win
this game or he should not win this game i don't
want he definitely won't because crazier things
have happened in mutual time trouble but right now
it's even material he does have to watch out for
allowing another rook on the last rank he could
find himself in a mating net but unlikely
i think he'll just scoot his rook back and
forth and king h2 can be played now how are
you going to check my name okay then we're
coming to g8 watch out oh he allows it but king
h3 so he made space for his king very important
you play rook to g1 now and offer the exchange of
rooks and now the rooks are off okay this is just
should it be a very very simple draw the bishop
will sacrifice itself they even agreed to it right
here okay we'll move on we'll move on let's go
back to the beast from leon what is happening here
how many extra pawns does black have just one
just one it looks like a million because i see
this phantom length of pawns here and i guess
maximi trace is gonna put a bishop on a7 the
bishop on g1 is overwhelmed h3 can come here
here comes the pawn storm here comes g4g well
not g4 now because of this pawn but well thank you
for allowing him mcqueen there goes uh maxime so
maxime wins by resignation let's keep on going
a wonderful time that is malaysian rook end game
okay this pawn is falling immediately going to
be a draw i see he's down the stretch in big fish
that is vladimir fedo say evan what the i've never
seen a position just like this before two bishops
against a bishop and two pawns this should be
a draw because with the bishop staying on this
diagonal there's no way to force the king into
the corner and deliver a checkmate nothing like
that so this game should just be drawn let
me look for more games here because we have
plenty of others still going on here let's
go to ah no i clicked on the wrong game that
didn't want to check out a game with two extra
queens nope don't want to check out this game
either the end of the round this is going to be
the situation here oh king g6 oh missed it okay
that's how you misplay a rook against pawn ending
and he had time to find it now that's that's sadly
inexcusable for a player of his caliber so that
is a huge missed opportunity there in well-known
easily winning position i'm going to take us
back to this moment here where it was winning
how do you play king of g6 first of all you
block the stalemate because the king wasn't
stalemate but now with the king of the g8
square you put your king on h6 with check
and after king to h8 the only way to save the
pawn i slide my rook over to a1 i give you a
check and i dislodge your king from the defense
of this h7 pawn so i go over here no longer is a
stalemate can come to jake thank you for this
check and now i win your pawn directly king
and rookie and king of course is a win and he had
another win even after he missed that opportunity
ah why does it go so far back i don't want to
go all the way back here let's go back here
so in this position um right here after
king g8 that's a mistake king g7 was correct
king g6 is played if you queen then the rook would
have went there for checkmate sad the next round
is underway that's what happens when you're doing
a speed chess tournament i need to remember that
i can't tell you everything i want to tell you
i am limited for a time so instead of being so
verbose i need to just get to my point man
so sad so sad all right let's go to some
other games here let's look at hmm let's go
to this one i'm gonna go to a new game where
um let's go to nemo's game actually we'll uh tune
in to nemo i didn't even see that she was playing
but of course we want to check in to see her
tournament seems like she's struggling out of
the gates but that's what happens in a field like
this she is wearing her jersey that's pretty cool
i like the color scheme in general i'm a fan of
these light blues so nemo taking part in this
event always good to see her hopefully she can
score some points and uh and she's always having a
good time that's the best thing about her streams
no matter her results she's enjoying herself she's
making sure that everyone's tuned in for a good
one speaking of results we gotta tune back in for
a car nakamura's stream real quick because hikaru
he's always getting those results and he's at a
perfect score 3-0 he's pushing his pawns here as
you see drawing many arrows and highlights oh gosh
i always learn from watching a card streams too
so it's good to see him in the form that he's
in today and we will likely if he maintains
the pace we'll see him in the knockout but
for now we're going to go to some other games
i have one up here between some great players
uh we have z kid taking on azeri chest that is
chakriar mama jarv so look at these these mutually
nice squares e4 covered by the pawns e5 covered by
the pawns and i think that if either side is going
to play for an edge here why play c4 which is a
somewhat risky move just because you're making d4
a little bit looser um but you're also obviously
putting pressure on d5 i was going to say
an idea with g4 comes to mind and you have to be
cautious before pushing pawns in front of your own
king but the center of the board is really clogged
up here and so look at mamajara put his king on
h8 there could be a rook g8 g5 of his own and well
i don't like that move at all i really don't like
that move because you're sort of shutting down
the opportunity to open up the center of the board
and unless you are quickly getting to the king
side first i see that black can get there do not
play rook g8 too soon there could be a knight
f7 check but taking on e4 probably not what
uh was really wanted by say oh and this knight is
trying to get to d5 perhaps you can also put your
rook on d8 and go right for this pawn here on d4
now the bishop should probably move out the way
the e6 pawn is hanging although it's not really
hanging because as soon as the queen takes on
e6 the bishop can take on c5 so it's sort of
fake hanging i do like black's position here
slightly i think he has a little bit of an edge
so well where to now where to now where do we go
should we stay here i'm trying to look for some
of these players where's cassie's fiddler's
game over here let's uh it's going
over to svidler's game why not he's 3-0
he's probably streaming usually is for these
events i see this d6 square and i get concerned
for black's position but then i recognize very
quickly it's black's turn because knight d6
actually wouldn't even be that powerful because
bishop could take on f3 but it's an idea to keep
an eye on so knight d6 there's going to be tactics
with knight takes c3 that's why harsha quickly
took on d5 the bishop takes back now there's no
knight d6 hitting the bishop on b7 if we trade
you fix my pawn structure i have these kind of
hanging pawns but it looks good for black in
that case you can take on c4 play knight e5 take
on f3 and take on b2 this is all going to happen
and i like spiller's position he's grabbing this
pawn on b2 and i if i am harsha i'm thinking about
taking this pawn c5 but then i don't like the
consequences of my double isolated f-pawns that
doesn't look very good so hey caro won his fourth
game i just saw that out of the corner of my eye
fiddler trying to do the same with the
black pieces what a nice sequence by him
when you have less control when you just have
fewer squares for your pieces trading often helps
you and that's exactly what further did in this
game and he is going to snag this can you play
f5 f5 is an interesting move he doesn't do that
but i was looking at f5 as a possibility there
it looked quite interesting because if you can
get your pawns pushed that also feels quite nice
but he takes the pawn he runs back this pawn c5
will be a target here comes rook c6 to win this
poem in c5 so he will not even be able to keep
this pawn but i wouldn't be unhappy about what's
happened here for peter i think he actually has
obtained quite a nice position from the black
side no real risk has safety everywhere in fact
it's white's pawn structure that is worse because
these are isolated pawns on the queen side so i
could see a future in this game where white loses
both of these pawns on the queen side for just
one and then has to fend off a four on three
advantage on the king side but svidler let's
look at his [ __ ] uh yeah so we'll we'll see
filler is streaming
and um doing very well so let's move on to another
game real quick we'll come back later he's going
to be at the top of the standings i believe for a
long time so i want to go to a wonderful time to
min lay let's go what's going on with the
black pieces here hey looks pretty nice for
him we're about to see an end game with bishops
of opposite color but look at this pawn on g5
that's the pawn that sticks out most because this
knight on e5 is good it puts pressure while it
defends uh this pawn over here i don't know why
the arrow went from h to g6 but this knight is
very good this nana c3 is quite limited and this
bishop can come to e3 and steal the g-pawn and
that's not a pawn you want to lose because that
becomes an outside passer for black so take on g5
you just move his bishop somewhere and then
go to g5 g4 and can you really stop that pawn
that's an important question because now bishop
f4 bishop oh gosh of course bishop d4 you have
completely dominated this knight you will take
the knight wherever it goes and then this g-pawn
runs free nicely done by wonderful time here
really he's just such an excellent player
but the way he went from that
initial position into this which
is pure domination across the board here
and he's going to try to promote this pawn
g2 91 check thank you for your bishop on g2 that
wins right now and here he does it it's too good
too good check and there's a piece so we'll get
go away from this game it looks like uh millie's
gonna win so let's go to this one between whoa
tuning in for a queen against a pair of rooks
but how many extra pawns do i have three extra
pawns and the king actually feels quite safe
this is looking really nice here for white and
lord balrog queen g6 i just pushed the pawns
so you have to be careful when you do things
like that but it looks like you're in time
because there's no easy way to stop them h7 queen
g7 is check and i guess of course the queen g8
helps me promote and that's it king h4
probably also good enough oh wait a sec
wait a sec what do you do about this pawn how
do you there must be a way here oh queen g five
queen g check you miss quinn g8 he gets the pawn
no that can't be right because now the two rooks
are doing quite well no there's no way this
is all of a sudden it's getting bad for white
the rooks actually are better than the queen
with just one pawn so the king is going to hide
he's going to play a6 eventually he's going to
double his rooks in the g file uh-uh this is no
good this is no good only can be good for black
who's going to take this pawn at the right time
so he's going to try to improve the position
of his king first but queen c5 check is nice
queen e5 check as possible and that's good
technique by white as well you want to keep
the king as far away from your pawns
as possible so c5 26 check so that's
not going to be played and i think the king is
going to be forced back into the corner again
and there we see a draw by repetition the point
is that if black let's say this king over here and
you make some move like c3 i would love to take it
a moment like this when your king is very far away
and my king perhaps gets here first now there's
still going to be opportunities for white to draw
but that's black's goal is at the king here and
not back on a8 it's very far away and then there's
gonna be no winning chances for kings back in the
corner so interesting end game there white missed
clear win i would say and we do have
just a few games left it looks like
castor is a perfect four four four let's uh keep
on going just down for the remaining games here
we have crescent moon isn't that grand master
um trung sun from vietnam if i'm not mistaken
that knight is trapped king g6 does this work it
looks like it works can you seven king of seven
oh stalemate king g6 aren't king here either
way stalemate and we see a draw so the very
strong vietnamese grandmaster cannot pull off the
victory and well we're heading down the stretch
here final games looks like dan laz wins his
game moves a three out of four just as we tune in
we have another end game here the knight should
be able to just wander around but don't watch
out for f4 you have to be very careful not to
allow a timely f4 and he plays it now g3 check
it's not where it was needed the king had to be
on h2 in order for this pawn thrust to really work
because now the knight can sacrifice itself
as it just happened and this is a draw well
without further ado i believe we are four rounds
in the books so we have um matlakov parham that is
oh my god corbin was like trying to figure
remember his name it's like gracia vidit my
good friend let's say komski and many more at a
perfect four or four but we're gonna head to break
we'll return more from the speed chest
champion grand prix brought to you by chess.com
patience is not a virtue
it is a weapon
what's your wow rabbit
so
and as we return the team is doing a fair play
check our the favorite process from chess.com
is robust and there is a team of fair play
professionals that use statistical methods in
manual view by top grandmasters over 500 million
games reviewed in 2020 for fair play i can't
count nearly that i can't count to 500 so that's
so many games there and many confessions from
very highly rated players title players and
it's uh unfortunate but more than a hundred
thousand closures over the last eight years so
chess.com is doing everything in its power to
fend off players who are not competing fairly it
is really a situation that is closely monitored
and that's the reason for these breaks in between
the rounds make sure that everything is how it
should be and i also want to point out as we look
at the overall leader board in the speed champion
grand prix that one name was left out thanks to
our viewers for pointing that out it is dmitry on
draken and you'll see him placed there behind
hike marti roshan and he's a very good chance
of making his way through if he can leapfrog hike
in the standings because he has actually switched
his username during the season and i think
that caused some confusion but nevertheless
we do have demetrion draken he is a superstar
i mentioned him earlier as one of the players
to keep an eye on but i didn't actually realize
when i was saying that that he is a potential
qualifier for the speed chess championship so
you know well we'll look at dimitri's games he's
such a strong player we see maxine chagaya we have
maximum vascular grove there so players are really
just trying to make their way into that fourth
qualification spot because it does feel like at
this point parham he's got things locked up nerdy
back and artemyev certainly doesn't he can't be
caught at this point so lots of great players
fighting for very few uh remaining places they
will see who ends up qualifying and i was asked
i saw the chat asking hey can you show a car's
checkmate during the intermission and oh i didn't
even know it i had to pull it up now for the first
time but that's a checkmate if i've seen one looks
like there's bishop b5 what a lovely move saying
please take me i can also play my pawn to c6 which
is what happened and the rook went to b6 to say
oh i have an intermezzo you take my queen i take
yours queen a7 takes and this king is out of space
that's beautiful that's beautiful stuff thank
you everybody for telling me informing me about
that and our next round is off let's start with
peters fiddler we have him streaming here he
uh is playing his game while keeping an eye on
the norway chess game wouldn't be surprised if
peter was actually commentating on that game
while playing his own and commenting on that
that's just how talented he is a great respect
for peter and he is doing quite well thus far
in the uh early stages of the speeches
championship grand prix today but uh we'll we'll
keep an eye on peter as you know he is obviously
a player that we'd love to see participating
and right now i have karjakin up the black
pieces i'm going to bring up on draken's game
as well if he's still in here somewhere because
we mentioned that he's somebody who's trying to
claw his way into the speedchest championship
and i'm gonna first you know keep our eye on
karjakin game explain a little bit then i'll go
over tom draken so karjakin is up a pawn here
this pawn on c4 is extra let's turn that green
because it's an extra pawn from black but what
white has a compensation for that pawn is a great
center let's get rid of that and flexibility and
the bishop on b7 doesn't look so good the pieces
for black at the moment aren't optimally placed
but if you can trace some of these off maybe
play c5 at the right moment without dropping b5
if you start trading pieces off black does have
this extra pawn so white is trying to put pressure
if you take on e5 take back with a pawn gain
some space for my knight on e4 but that's why
black is just refraining from the time being and
it does feel like c5 now can be played and if c5
is safely played black is just so much better
uh with the extra pawn but there goes the uh
the sirens there goes the ambulance and maybe
it's for my evaluation the position because i
did just see after rook a to d8 the evaluation
bar off to the side says no not so fast white is
actually doing okay here even though i tend
to like black's chances in such a position
g4 will not help because if c5 does indeed
happen you're making your own king weaker
kayaking plays it let's move on to our guy
dimitri on draken we're gonna move on there
so let's see on draken is the white pieces against
the i can't even call him a feeding master alexis
sorokin is like 25 40 classical feed it the
guy is grand master in everything but title
but yet he has an fm title so it's the kramnik
kramnik was an fm rated like 2590 and um sorokin
doesn't have the title but he certainly has the
rating and this position is an exchange up for
black and it's a clear exchange not even a pawn
for that exchange but watch out for the king look
at these dark squares in front of and next to
this black king bishop c3 queen to d4 queen e5
and go in for checkmate that's obviously a main
idea here now black isn't going to allow that
so if queen e5 queen f6 that's the point let
me just keep offering this trade i'll go back
you go back like we'll just go back and forth
and try to make a draw here white is better
and he plays queen e5 so queen f6 has to
be played because there's a mate on h8
he's gonna go back to e3 you're not trading queens
here you can play queen to c7 but then watch out
for rook c8 so queen 27 does not work rook c8 is a
nice move just offering up your exchange in return
and getting the open c file so zip queen to d6
now he didn't play this immediately he could have
and one of the issues is a timely bishop c4
bishop e5 like a d6 check trying to open up an
attack on this king and the queen is a bad block
hitting piece another issue is queen h6 comes
at some moment and your queen is on f7
where it defends your king of course you
can put your rook on f7 to defend some of these
squares so here queen d4 but then there's e5
now that is i have to show this on the board
queen d4 e5 you take on poisson i take your queen
when you take the queen back you lose the
bishop at the end of this so e5 is a really
really nice move that would shut down the
diagonal and give black a huge advantage
so bishop e5 played first this bishop can drop
back to b3 but when it drops to b3 this bishop
can come to c2 to offer an exchange of bishops i
do not like the way this is going for on draken
a queen b6 there could be queen h6 but then
there's rook f7 so okay bishop d4 played queen
back to d6 i imagine and we may very well see an
attempt to draw a bishop c2 what's wrong with that
that's something i'm still looking at
offering a trade of bishops in fact forcing
a trade of bishops that one can not
move anywhere besides taking on c2 and
i'm starting to like black's position more and
more not that objectively it's that much better
but you see how this game is going the
trajectory of the game it went from
potential attack for white to now white just
trying to stave off the swapping of pieces
because that will only favor black so i think that
and draken he needs to figure this out quickly and
he doesn't really want to make a draw but perhaps
it draws his best bet so maybe he'll continue
bishop d4 bishop e5 and say all right alexi you
play well you fended me off here i got nothing
and still no move is bishop d4 a draw but no it
would not be a force draw so i was wondering if
like he's about to make the draw and that's why
he's thinking by the way peters fiddler did win
his game so congrats to him he continues to ascend
the in the standings all right so bishop d4 played
at long last queen came back to d6 of course
protecting e7 keeping e6 check off the table
yeah i think we're gonna queen d7 look at black
playing on now i think it's very smart d6 check
bishop takes queen takes here it comes and
then black will play e6 in the end of this line
and the good news is this bishop is incredible
on e5 but actually rook f7 very nice move if
you played e6 that would have given white a
protected pass pawn and white would have played
f4 with a pawn on d6 so this is an improvement
for black who's going to put the king on h7
and now g7 and h8 are under control so sorokin
playing well his king still has to be cared for
and if that's the case it's not going
to be so easy to win this position
but here he comes queen c5 this piece to come out
watch out for maybe a rook at fade at some moment
like right now bishop d4 there's queen c4 or
queen f5 queen c4 does pin this bishop and and
attacks a2 just you can take this a2 pawn there's
no threats here these squares are under black's
control not white so he's trying to do a queen g5
queen h6 that's clear by putting the bishop on e3
and look at the queen swing right over
to f5 nicely done very nicely done
here come the pieces you in fact don't even have
the attack that you once thought you might because
you're doing the bishop on a1 and making use of
the diagonals so black has done a great job of
coordinating his pieces he's now opening exchange
and upon this could be it for on draken's chances
perhaps if he doesn't make it to the knockout
he will have to win all the rest of his games
to have a chance usually it's eight and a half
points that makes the knockout if you lose this
one really rough start for him i always have to
start the middle of the tournament at this point
and hikaru did win his game i see that it
looks like mama jarv won his game karjakin won
so just keeping an eye on some of those
results there as we see komski in first place
and tai is well did it we're gonna have
to look at vin's game next round i think
so there's no attack here is queen rook d6
one move threat the queen dropped back can i
just push the spawn why not the rook covers the d7
square and rook c1 doesn't work queen f5 that just
ices the game trade the queens here it is game
over queen c2 funny move it's like a resignation
so that was a nicely played game by sorokin he
beats on draken let's go back to min why not he
has a chance squad oh but this is not good for
him it's two knights against a rook and a pawn
now just by material that should be okay for black
but not in this endgame when this pawn is hard to
stop over here and there are two of
them look at this king h3 is a threat
because this knight is under attack so the
knights are needed protecting one another
and they can't actually move because
if you move the g5 knight you lose e4
movie 4 you lose g5 oh gosh giving up
this ground is no good h3 takes this
and rook c2 check and then rook c8 our rxc1
is better maybe and then push to spawn so win
and wonderful time is going down to this one
king c2 okay you would have won the game qc3
not bringing the king in all right it doesn't
matter too much because it's completely winning
position but uh maybe not the most accurate
technique and i mean it does resign the game so we
have a few more games to see parham is playing oh
two knights against a rook but this is different
because it's two knights pure for a rook and the
king should go back to g2 i don't know why it's
running where it is and you need to get your
king to f3 but king g5 knight check oh but there
will be rook rook f2 with here kh4 so knight
3 king h4 and knight f4 those rook takes f2 so
we'll check here and if you take this pawn
does chess.com make this an immediate draw
oh i actually okay king takes h3 would have
been played so it would have been immediate draw
but this is technically a drawn position there's
no way to win except for a help checkmate
but i would have liked to see it been played
out because it's not always so easy but okay
here also king takes h3 would have uh resulted in
a draw okay timo feyev just pushing the pawns we
saw at mexican version of in a similar position
earlier in the event with a phalanx of pawns on
the king side where his opponent tried to promote
pawns of zone this bishop is doing a great job of
blockading and hear f2 bishop takes h2 thank
you for this queen on h1 and timofev wins the
game i think our viewers may not be so familiar
with timofeo but he is an exceptionally strong
grandmaster and doing very well now with
four and a half points out of five games
one game remaining chess player 99 19
taking on moscolenko and this looks
like a complete and utter draw there really
is very little to think about at this point
just move your king with your rook don't get
checkmated not too difficult to accomplish
so
so that was a draw
all right so we're getting next round here
with hikaru taking on uh groucho let's uh
stay i would say we're going to look at vidic's
game guess the car was 5-0 we still do expect him
to make his way all the way through and let's uh
look at vidit because we haven't seen him this
game once and he usually is streaming over there
on youtube and he is the black pieces against
amin tabatabai and what's always funny to me is
because video just started this account and he's
playing while streaming his rating is 28.57 he
is underrated grossly underrated on this account
i think his rating is somewhere in the ballpark
of 29.50 usually or above 2900 that's for sure
but he's taking on a very strong player from
iran and right now we see this carlsbad set up
with pawns from b7 to d5 here you sometimes would
like to push this pawn up from b2 to b5 use a pawn
minority attack and why is it called that black
has three pawns here and white has just two and
you're the one who's trying to crash through
because you have an open line for your rook
so so far very normal position do not move this
knight away from f6 because you drop the d5 pawn
as the pawn c6 pin to the queen so knight e4
would be a big blunder because of knight takes d5
so just keep that in the back of your minds so 95
is sometimes possible here if you take i take with
the pawn and then i have knight takes d5 so did
it preemptively protects this pawn of the time
dropping his bishop back and that means that if
95 i can take because now white is the one who
can't take with the pawn e5 because there's d4 so
just show that very quickly that i put the bishop
on e6 to open up a line of attack on the queen
and then attack his knight on c3 so queen c2 is
dropped back first so if you do want to take with
the d pawn had to move the queen away and what's
going on here e4 at some point can be considered
for white it leaves you with an isolated pawn so
not always mentally that easy to play but it is
a standard idea now i wouldn't be so sure because
black is ready to challenge on the open line and
there may be a way to play bishop d3 move the
knight away from after play f3 yourself and pushed
upon e4 so he does trade off this knight from e4
and i guess white is claiming semi open c file
black can't really initiate any pawn breaks
he's not that i see so he should be
slightly better nothing major here though
okay let's uh move on from this game we've been
here for a large farther now let's go back to
that hikaru nakamura game because i just saw an
inter mezzo being played f7 check by hikaru so
he could have taken his queen back right away but
he probably didn't want to allow this pawn to take
on f6 so by playing f7 check you keep this pawn
stuck in its place and then you take back on g3
next move and that's quite important because this
knight would like to go the e4 square but if there
are pawn on f6 that could potentially go to f5
that's a nice way to challenge not to mention the
pawn f6 covers a squarely e5 look at this knight
going right into e5 pawn to f4 i think that car
made a very smart decision here here comes c3
open up the c line for this rook and the c line
something i said c lion so trying to maneuver
the pieces and just at every advantage
possible in the position so c3 trying to open up
this rook the problem is hey maybe the b3 pawn is
an issue c4 now is possible it forces on poisson
otherwise you lose the e6 bond but we're going
to trade this rook is going to have to come to
e3 i believe to protect the pawn on b3 but this
pawn and this pawn are problem pieces for black so
rook c5 bishop b3 knight b3 rook to b3 this is all
going out may work to be one first is necessary
because rook b1 you can't play bishop d5 because
i'll take on b7 and at the end of this i'll have
a check on the seventh rank so if rook b1 forces
either rook to b or rook to d7 rook d7 doesn't
work because knight f3 comes into e5 with a
fork on this rook and this king so i know i'm
thinking very tactically here but after rook to b1
there's rook to b8 and then i can trade everything
on b3 and take on a5 instead he goes this way
and there may be a check here comes rick to c6
pinning this pawn once the king comes up to f6
the rook can only go to e8 to defend the pawn and
then this rook can come to a6 to win the pawn a5
so it is a very interesting sequence by hikaru but
maybe rook to b4 is possible giving up the e pawn
to win white's a pawn he does not do that
instead as i was saying protect c6 gives
up a5 this is an extra pawn in an end game
for hikaru very good winning chances because
this pawn e6 is an isolated pawn that will
require some serious defense from black
so i'm liking the look of hikaru's position
definitely liking his chances here and this is
going to be a very difficult defensive task
for a boar scratch chef if he's even able to
hold it so we'll come back here in a moment
i'm just trying to look and find as many games
as possible we'll go to peter's fiddler's game
really quickly i'll come back to the cars game
of course you can watch these players as they're
streaming on their own channels i just saw a pawn
f5 move and i don't know who this is but
i see a grand master from spain so i could
check it out in a bit but there is a pin
on the g pawn which is why the bishop is
immune from capture but black's pieces also
are coming really into the game nicely here
bishop d2 i could see a rook d h being
nice there's no attack against black's king
you have a semi-open file but you also have
an isolated pawn on e5 and black has isolated
pawns of his own a6 and c5 but i like the way that
black's pieces are coordinating here and there's a
pin down the d file the bishop can't move the rook
is hanging behind it could be a tough position
for white going forward c4 is check but you have
to be careful about your king over here so c4
he plays it and after key okay play c3 that's
the move i'm looking at because queen takes c3
i can finally take your bishop i don't know if
it works it actually may walk into some kind of
checkmate or maybe uh just a bunch of
checks that i can't get out of but c3
the bishop can't capture because there's a pin
so it said bishop e8 very safe and sound move
bishop g4 so that way the bishop protects the
rook all right this game is and you can just
win a pawn maybe put the bishop on f7 and say
thank you for the material looks right to me
just take on e6 you can play f5 but then bishop
f5 i'm trying to take advantage of this rook
not being defended there so he plays queen d4 he's
going right for please move your bishop can i take
it queen d1 okay piss queen e4 he's smarter than
i am sacrificing pieces that don't belong to me
as is typical but i still like black's position
because black's king for the time being looks
safer these bishops are in a great spot here and
white does feel a little bit tied down and we're
only seven seconds left and even notice that queen
e3 watch out for b3 okay we can trade queens but
if we trade queens there's no way to win this game
anymore unless this king somehow runs that quickly
no it's a draw okay let's go back to the cars game
he's trying to i'm just trying he's winning this
end game he's up three pawns now so he car stole
the eight pawn and stole the rest and a6 and then
push some of these all of them can go forward too
many extra pawns three many extra balls actually
so we gave up the a pawn but
he didn't take it and now
f5 can come to g5 no good yeah just resignation
resigns let us look at kayaking's game against
uh harsha we've seen harsher play before in this
event wait can you play b2 he's gonna sack
his queen for the rook and then played b2
oh that looks scary but somehow this queen covers
everything wait this isn't hanging oh my gosh
sergey you could have queen and protected
the pawn but you have no time in your clock
so if white plays for a win he might lose so
he's playing for the draw okay sergey no buddy
right here look at this he's trying to play rook
c6 because he saw queen f5 coming but b1 equals
queen actually defends this pawn and he had
no time on his clock i get it it's very hard
to play with two seconds but queen promotion
that actually also defends and black should be
winning next movie you can play rook to g8 so
that's a sad miss opportunity for sergey he's
still doing very well plenty of time left
in this tournament he will need to continue
whoa i'm like confused black is down in exchange
white should be kind of crushing here but how do
you make progress you need to kick this knight
out and go for the f7 pawn okay well rook takes
up seven is just a free pawn so the knight kicked
itself out and oh let's check mate let's check me
um well the rook and the knight and the
queen and these pieces are sad over here
yikes okay let's see if there
any more games yet left excuse me
we have a couple oh queen and bishop versus queen
should be an easy hold just trade queens that's it
and is that the last game of that round
oh we have one more
okay now we have hikaru taking on alex
sure 1981 don't know that is but let's uh
let's start a new cars game cars 6 out
of 6 deserves our our attention here
obviously brilliant player great streamer and
perfect score in this scc gp so a quieter opening
setup thus far or is you can play f4 though
that's the question because if white plays f4
it goes from quiet to potentially quite chaotic
and wouldn't be surprised if white plays some
kind of bishop e3 it's the move that players
who are worried about potentially losing to
a car we played knight a4 okay similar like
length that quiet move to attack your bishop
try to get the bishop pair i like the decision
honestly i think it's a good call so let's see
so trades gets the bishop pair you can
play f4 if you want you can also just play
quieter black can play knight a5 at some point
so you may want to keep an eye on his bishop
so after knight a5 now there's check bishop a4
bishop c2 you slide the back bishop back into
c2 so you keep the bishop pair and i wouldn't be
surprised if white plays bishop b5 here trying to
keep the bishop pair and now play d4 with the
idea of d5 so why is the bishop pair important
when you have the dynamic of a knight
against a bishop and you only have one bishop
the color complex that is not the color of your
bishop can be quite exciting it can become quite
vulnerable so if you trade your light square
bishops then the light squares can be useful
for the black knights because this bishop on
c1 can't actually help you fend off the light
squares so that's one of the reasons why you
often see players keep both bishops when you
start with the two bishops advantage instead of
just trading off the a pair of bishops so f5 by
a car that was the benefit of putting the bishop
on e6 you took away this pin from c4 to g8 and now
here comes f5 black's position is better in my
eyes everything is safe and sound no weaknesses
d4 is met by politics e4 how the d5s were covered
and f3 i mean f3 is not exactly a move that gives
you much confidence whereas d5 certainly does
there is a nice three pawns in a row on the fifth
rank and what is what are these pawns doing on d3
and f3 they're more passive pawns defending the e4
square whereas black is the one applying pressure
immediately in the position so i definitely like
hikaru's position here the pawn a2 can also be a
target at some point watch out for queen c5 check
and that's why he takes on c6 do you take with
the pawn or the knight that's the question and
not an easy one to answer because if you
take with the pawn you reinforce your center
and if you take it upon the black snipe can be
captured if that's what white was looking for
i don't think you really want to do that but you
may have to because black is going knight g6 and
i play f4 your bishop gets trapped over here
so you don't want to strain the bishop either
and car's position looks excellent his time
management looks excellent watch out for f4
i've been talking about this move and
it's important to note that this c6
pawn defends d5 so if you take on d5 i just
replace my pawn with another pawn oh gosh
look at these pawns here it's not
letting me highlight that one there we go
four on the fifth ring okay c4 c4 which
am i do i push it do i take somewhere
now it's a difficult moment because i still like
black's position i'm just not entirely sure how to
continue from this point forward
i think d4 looks reasonable
i don't really want to capture i'd say can i
capture it this way probably fe4 it plays d4
first that's as i was mentioning the first one
that came out i'm looking at b5 and c4 by the way
and he plays f4 just to gain space now g7 and g5
push these pawns could be an idea knight to h4
could be an idea but i'm looking at b5 takes in
c4 not anymore because after b5 takes c4 there's
bishop b4 and that's a problem but my essential
point was if you took on c4 i'd have d3 so just
trying to advance my pawns forward here but
it doesn't work out so the position remains
closed here comes g5 if you take with a bishop
now there's c5 saying hey you have one move
attack i'm blocking that good for you and this
rook coming f6 will be extra powerful defending
the pawn on b6 while helping to play g5 g4 right
you put the rook rook f6 for g6 and play g4
push forward here this is just a great position
for black who has so much more space and
okay g4 played if you take how is white going to
take back because it does open up the f-file and
the rook on f8 barrels right down with this
pawn f3 so that's a risky decision but is
someone that is somewhat standard and look at
a car that is how strong he is he says you know
what to heck with the king side i'm going over
here on the queen side and i have an extra pawn
from the b through the h-file it's seven on
seven in terms of number of pawns but black
has an extra pawn because this a3 pawn is off on
the side and is cemented in place so look at him
go he's trying to take on c4 and that will free up
his d4 pawn and we'll see just a trade here okay
after the trade on c4 you can take on g5 takes you
to the pawn i would probably think with the queen
on c4 because with the queens on the board this
pawn is more of a target it feels like and just
there's a potential issue with more places and
here comes rook to b3 this just looks bad no
matter what honestly yeah rook b3 you can take on
a4 too if you want to ruby 3 is obviously smart
watch out f3 is hanging a4 is
hanging c4 is under pressure
d3 actually was a possible move because i had
to go to c3 and then c4 drops but now d3 there's
knight to g1 may rook to b8 to get your rook to
b2 rook to e3 as possible everything is possible
sounds like a nice hallmark card but i mean
just black position is completely dominant
so
okay trades c4 is hanging and
then e2 is hanging as well
a4 is still hanging d3 is possible
and then queen d4 check for instance
queen a6 just saying your queen gets no squares
and here come oh c4 i didn't want to play c4
interesting i guess c4 would like queen b4 or
something like that but i'm looking at these c4
type of moves and just pushing the pawns forward
so card down to 20 seconds going down to 10
could be a bit of a time scramble he does play c4
queen e6 keeping the knight protected
keeping the palm protector c3 looks good
knight c6 probably wins this pawn
directly and by probably it does
okay so not that much time though akara needs to
be careful so does his opponent of course but i'm
saying it from a car's point of view because he
has a much better position so bishop b7 look at
that trading the queens off that's trade queens
i have an extra pawn and my pawns are doing
really well over here knight on g6 protecting e5
protecting e7 queen c4 would have traded queens
bunsen goes queen a6 bishop v5 uh oh that's it
that's all you need that's a pin and a win and a
win on the clock as well so a car wins
the game let's go over to uh min oh
he's in trouble too weak too slow is
neither too weak nor too slow at this point
yeah min is just midnight's
done for there and uh okay
so let's see if there any more games ringing up
plenty what am i even need to ask the question
a mean type of value down a pawn here but should
defend this end game the rook is perfectly placed
the king king has come to d8 and if king d6
there's rook to d2 check keeping the king away
so now you just give a bunch of checks put the
king in front of the pawn give a bunch of checks
rook d2 roxy 2 rook b2 etc and this is just a
draw what you would need for white is to put this
pawn back on c5 and bring your king to c6 but not
possible game is a draw let's keep on going okay
we have matthias blue bomb with the black pieces
as queen f5 dropping the c6 pawn but giving the
oh actually is it perpetual can i win the c3
pawn i feel like black can try to play on here
well now bishop b4 is super solid i was going
to take on c3 though and try to push the c pawn
that looked a little more likely but black
is actually down opponent even realized that
i was so focused on the center of the board
that i didn't realize that black is the one
who to some extent needs to be careful bishop
f8 there's bishop g6 okay bishop back to b4
yeah if the queens come off it's immediately
a draw wait bishop hate bishop hate oh my gosh
big blunder here queen h6 check there's no mate i
want to play g4 but that's pin so i can't get away
with that bishop d6 or queen f4 check it's only
a check kingdom's e6 and there are opportunities
even down two pawns if the queens get traded okay
26 queen d7 queen h7 that's not winning the queen
okay that's pawn on c3 uh-oh bishop v6 bishop
e7 you can you could have brought his bishop
down that way to win the f-bomb so white is
in business here some blunders by blue bound
but even if the queens get traded oh
queen e7 check check and win this pawn
oh no no no no no that's what i was talking about
if you trade the queens there's going
to be very good chances to hold this
oh maybe it doesn't look so horrible anymore
well trade that's important keeping those
pawns on the board felt important but maybe
just push the g6 and push the bishop here
yeah the presence of these pawns not good qg5
h6 h7 bishop v5 yikes and blue bomb goes down
brolic is a happy camper here 87 mate
thank you very much and that is checkmate
so let's see any more games going on yes indeed
no one no that one's not going on just kidding
clicking on a game that i thought was going on but
in fact it was over so with that seven rounds are
in the books hikaru and clear first followed by
parham amin zubaii that is shakira mamjarov and
a whole host of players there with the six out of
seven we're gonna take another fair play break and
when we return we'll have the final three rounds
the swiss as we get ready for the knockout portion
of the speeches championship grand prix brought
to you by chess.com patience is not a virtue
it is a weapon what's your wow rabbit
and during these breaks while players take
a little bit of rest you know stretch their
wrists from moving at the speed of light the fair
play team is practicing the event as you can see
here there are 17 full-time team members including
five statisticians seven chief detectives and five
title player manual review experts and the checks
are happening in real time dedicated proctors
everybody is trained so it's uh it's really good
to help prevent cheating or to make sure that
people who do so do not get away with it but right
now we know that hikaru nakamura he is at seven
out of seven the only completely perfect score
we have three players who have dropped just a
half point parham maksoudlu amin tabithabayi and
shakira mamjarov and then we have many players
sitting with six out of seven points including
nerdy back abductor if he's in eighth place the
chess warrior but without further ado
we have a liftoff i see the games are
underway let's start with karjakin i know
i've tuned in quite a bunch to his game so
it's because he's on the outside looking in if we
talk about the overall leaderboard for the sec gp
he needs to make it to the knockout and maybe
even win the knockout to qualify automatically
for the speeches championship so here he
goes with the black pieces playing the azeri
grimmaster vulgar rasulov nothing too special
just yet by the way hikaru is taking on parham
and he carved with the white pieces he takes the
approach that he played and gets magnus many times
with this capturing on c6 a delayed exchange
spanish and look at the e4 square that's one
for white's pieces and that's what he's
going to claim is his advantage if you
can put his knight on e4 for example and then
even go g4 g5 that knight not only blockades
some of the squares here it can help you launch an
attack on this square like f6 but the d5 square is
available to blacks knight as well so
parham's position so far it's a tale of these
central light squares and part goes knight c8 to
go knight to d6 and then trade off the knight on
e4 so that's actually quite a safe approach by
parham here knight d6 next let me trade off your
wonderfully placed p74 and that's that so let's uh
keep on looking down the list of players we have
amin tabai taking on shakira mama jarv nothing
too special just yet standard opening position
the bishop on h2 is currently blocked by this
pawn on e5 but if that pawn ever pushes to e4 the
bishop gets a new lease on life in this position
so bishop f5 played hitting the queen saying do
go e4 try that because it frees up a square like
d4 later for my knight to reroute into the game
excuse me so we saw a swap on d3 white is first
to the d file but it doesn't really amount to all
that much because where are the weak points in
order to use an open line or to try to claim an
advantage you need to start attacking things but
what are you going to attack e5 is safe and sound
these pawns on the queen side perfectly okay
there's nothing major going on to my eyes an h5
gives the king some space it's not really going
for an attack it's more about giving the king
some space so if a piece ever lands on the eighth
rank it's not going to result in some awkward
tie ups so let's keep on going we have um many
games of course still in action here let's go to
vidit's game video guzrati he is taking on the
chess warrior that's nerdy becca mustard off
and wait knight b5 is the threat what knight
b5 is or knights d4 okay maybe there's knight
to z4 but i've just said knight b5 and now
i have to really calculate here knight b5
knight takes d4 and what is happening
there so let's let's try this knight b5
takes and oh my gosh i can take here first that
looks really smart because now everything's under
attack we're gonna go to the live board see if it
happens he played knight b5 step one complete but
knight d4 rook takes c7 the both queens
are under attack and i understand what
black's idea was if knight d4 and you
take on d6 i take on c1 with check first
and here it comes rook takes c7 shouldn't win i
mean i'm looking at this position trying to figure
out all the tactics here but rook c7 if you take
my queen i take your rook with check here it comes
here comes in vidic gujrathi looks like he's
going to go to seven out of eight with this game
so right now white is up a rook for just a pawn
and if i take on e2 for example then this queen
is under attack and white's queen is not so after
92 the king just hop over the corner or play king
f1 one of those moves would be good so he plays
knight 62 check is out of desperation because he
realized he made a mistake and i both moves look
totally fine but king h1 feels a bit safer to me
and this queen is under attack this rook is under
attack so the bishop can't even take on b5 because
you lose this rook back here with check and not
just check but uh likely a background checkmate
wow what a sequence here and he plays king f1
going after this i think knight g3 check is
possible that's why i was saying not to play king
f1 knight g3 if you take on g3 bishop b5 now is
check to the king and then i pick up your rook
after that i know that's a lot to calculate there
so many pieces flying into position but the point
is bishop b5 would be check if not for the knight
so now bishop b5 was the threat the king came all
the way to e1 and if this works it's just winning
but i didn't really want to bring the king all the
way out to e1 here queen b6 so take and then you
just take this and now you have a full rook so
vida guzrati is up a full rook in this position
barring some kind of absolutely crazy
blunder you should just be taking this one
home queen a5 is just one check you can start
running your king back over to the king side
and that's that nicely done by vida gujarati
here so let's uh move on from this one let's
go to hikaru's game against parham because it's
akaru and whoa okay so that's one check and you
can pick up b7 but he didn't want to go because
rook to b at the end of that f2 look at this
pawn here that's a really strong pawn protected
by a piece d4 is a possibility but black has c5
to try to get after that oh gosh rookie eight okay
and is there some kind of just see i mean white's
king is not exactly that happy over here and if
you take and the bishop takes well protected here
so this pawn really strong if you take with
the pawn d4 there'll be a queen c4 check
so it's starting to look like a problem for hikaru
so d3 comes to mind not sure it works but d3 check
is something that comes to mind d takes c3 of
course is also looking quite interesting because
the queen is needed to defend this bishop so after
d takes e3 you can't take with the queen on uh
see there's a d3 check was played rook takes
can't take with the queen stick with the king
because this bishop wait what gives it the bishop
he's trying to get some kind of queen d7 check so
he realized the position was losing regardless
so he's going for some sort of attack he is
up two seconds and in a mutual time scramble
anything can happen but black is up a piece
for just one queen to check oh okay well queen
e4 is even better wins the rook nice by parham
and hikaru is going to lose this game he's still
in great shape seven out of eight but not a game
he wanted to lose of course and very stubborn
defense turned into offense for parham because
well back way back here the queen aaa check
was probably what he carrier wanted to play
but after king d7 queen take a b7 rook to b8 you
have to watch out because b2 is falling and that's
obviously not what you're looking for let's go
back to karjakin with the black pieces completely
winning here he is up no material actually wow
i thought he was up the pawn but i saw the past
pawn potential with the spawn trying to come c3
so he's gonna take on a4 don't allow bishop to c6
that's checkmate so you need to stop
that and play rook to d6 good move
and now you can come to b4 there's no more
checkmate so you're just winning the game
so you gotta just watch out for one turn king
b5 he's gonna rook b6 next i think so but if
you trade there's always knight to d6 at the
end and here come the pawns here come the pawns
knight d6 hitting the rook protecting protecting
everything this knight is just an octopus knight
and after bc3 is king c5 and then b2 kraken
wins moves to seven of eight so he may even face
hikaru nakamura in the next game it's a
possibility so we have lord balrog taking
on borscht uh that is matlikov and i think lord
balrog is kusadinov so i'm not mistaken and well
this is going to be a win for wait a sec this
could be two nights against the king which would
be a draw so what white should do oh terrible
move he pre-moved it it was a horrible move
oh my gosh that stinks from him oh but now
he's going to win he kicked the bishop away
oh he's going to win anyway what just happened
what'd he do matlikov you you're gifted a piece
you're gifted a piece
oh a vey just like here knight f7 the idea was
if the bishop stayed here let's say the king
went here knight f7 is good because you played
g6 g7 jade and queen but he pre-moved knight f7
which is a horrible blunder and after king takes
knight e5 you just have to be careful not to allow
this pawn to get to g6 so here king g4 check i
mean sorry check here king e4 is the wrong way
it's keep your king attach the pawn because if
knight to g7 you have this bishop f7 it's very
important that you keep your king as close to the
pawn as possible really difficult to see in time
trouble but the essential point is that you want
to be able to sacrifice your bishop for the pawn
in some manner it doesn't have to be directly it
doesn't have to be bishop captures pawn it just
means that when your bishop is lost you also steal
that final pawn so that was the way to do it and
that's a missed opportunity by matlikov let's go
to the final few games that we have here we have
mazdovich that is sebastian mazet and while knight
e1 f3 check is just winning i have to check mate
don't even take the rook in the corner okay he
took it didn't need to and he's winning with black
let's make 23. gigi all right so we're
let me look at the standings i haven't
paid attention too much parham
and mama jarvis seven up to eight
hikaru karjakin i'm not sure who alex sur is but
once i know i'll let you know uh that's komski
we have um ivan panzulaya and because dino kuzovov
did it some great players up there okay i wouldn't
be surprised if this game doesn't draw very
quickly you know how i feel about quick draws
but i imagine a draw will be offered relatively
soon let's see how many movies do you think four
okay we already have to move three
oh no draw well we might get a game
so we actually are getting a game we're getting
some mainline spanish where you think oh i want
to take on b3 but black almost never does because
that helps white finish off some development here
oh who knew i knew and that's a draw it was
ten moves so excuse me for saying four moves
but i knew that the draw would happen because
obviously let's go to hikaru against vidit
and car puts up on f3 which
opens this bishop up and
does not allow white to castle so i'm not sure i
love this from hikaru's point of view right now
he plays f4 okay so a knight can come to g4
trying to get to f2 that looks quite annoying
in fact it looks extremely annoying
what do you do after knight to g4
i'm like h6 after it
not sure i'm buying this knight g4 okay f takes e5
is possible i used to play the vienna as white so
i know that sometimes you can take on e5 and
get your queen out and try to like deliver a
checkmate against black but didn't like this
is the position because queenie too quickly
so bishop f4 now you can throw in bishop f2
check if you want that's something that's
a nuisance but now bishop f2 the king can come to
d2 instead of having to oh that's a double attack
and the bishop has to stay protecting
this knight as well wait a sec
this is kind iffy territory right now to
be very very careful in this position can't
castle right you can't guess up through
check if you play rook f1 there may even
be knight takes h2 and the point of knight h2
is after bishop h2 i take your knight on g5
this doesn't look very good of course
after work f1 b2 is also hanging that's
not out of the question but i didn't like after
queen b2 there's knight takes f7 so
you have to be careful about that
as the king would have to walk into the line of
the rook so knight takes h2 does hit this rook
i think that's just a good move
although there could be some kind of
e5 type of movie to keep an eye out on
not as easy as i'm making it sound but knight
takes h2 looks very very possible here knight h2
e5 queen f5 keep the queen attached to that
knight on g5 i think that it will find it
there he goes knight takes h2 and this is
dangerous territory for hikaru because he
cannot afford to lose this game if he wants
to make it to the knockout stage same with
it eight and a half points is the qualification
number and as you see that parham and mama jar
are both eight out of nine of their quick
draw so eight and a half points that's what
you need so losing this game would likely
kick either player out of the knockout
and you see a car sitting and thinking now
realizing oh this is a problem for me because my
bishop is overloaded defending h2 and defending
g5 and then black has the bishop here to boot
so what to do here i think you
probably have to take on h2
and bring the bishop back to f4 he does that queen
h4 g3 so you can reinforce the bishop here queen
g4 looks pretty good you are a pawn but actually
this stops by excuse me white from castling
because if you castle bishop g4 lands
on the board and you lose in exchange
bishop e3 queen e3 queen g2 not recommended that's
exactly the type of transition that white would
want castle coins it's still not possible
because of bishop g4 that's a big nuisance
so a car still can't castle he can take on b6
but then a takes b6 and you're opening the a
file knight c5 played okay i like that move it's
reasonable i think you can okay just castles right
away still can't castle queen side for white
because of bishop g4 okay that move did not
come recommended bishop g4 still looks fine if
white can't castle it's not going to be so fun
it takes in c5 first plays a6 so vivid
playing the solid approach but now
castle and queen side still can't be played
because bishop g4 so unfortunately for a car
not able to castle buddy plus queen f2 i
would look out for the a7 square from did it
that bishop can move to say e7 and then queen a7
that could be a problem so in fact after bishop
e7 he doesn't diego's king d2 his king is just
going to castle by hand after rookie team e1
here comes rk1 and honestly voice position is
not so bad it's an extra pawn for black but
obstacle bishops for the long term
it means that reduced winning chances
so who else is in the running here we have many
people looks like oh we have another player
joining at eight out of nine so i think there's
gonna be a bunch of people at the top let's go
to the game between com actually there's king on
c3 but i'm going to go to the game between cops
and kayaking real quick just see what's happening
here as both players have seven and eight kamsky
with the white pieces he's up a pawn and this
pawn is probably going to be lost in the future
so komski in great shape to take down karjakin
it's a good show of this here this pawn on a
and c4 permanently weak and he offers a trade so
that when he takes an eight his bishop comes right
back to d5 and he wins c4 so he has gone up two
pawns in the ensuing ending whether or not it's
easy to win that remains to be seen but it looks
like a winning position you take the pawn you move
the king up start marching your pawns put all
these pawns and light squares should be winning
just don't be left with only the h pawn look
at the corner look at the bishop corner don't
match so you would not want to trade f pawns
kamsey's not going to do that let's go back to
the car against video game um oh by the way komsky
actually won my resignation as soon as i turned
away bishop d4 queen a7 okay if it has to be very
careful here but it's rook d6 mission d4 so the
king is trying to run away 25 check queen e5 means
that he'll he can't be worse as he is up a pawn
and what's happening here so can't get g5
h4 in this bishop can always park on g5
is at some point uh-oh this reminds me of
um hikaru's win over magnus down upon the
start of the bishop of opposite color and rook's
position but better bishop better pawn structure
and he car's gonna try to win this one rook g5
putting the bishop on f7 then walk the king in
start walking this king in okay bishop v8 good
idea buy bidded to try to get the open line
trade trade rooks i don't think he can lose this
game i mean he can lose it time trouble is a uh
thing but should not be losing though white
is about to have tons of pawns moving forward
c5 presumably it was b5 he played with two
seconds left by the way c takes d4 bishop g2
king e6 or c6 nice move in the king e6 now it's a
draw bishop h1 bishop g2 back and forth keep the
king tied to the spawn there's no way that
white should be able to make progress here
and this is just going to be a draw there's not
even really a winning attempt here for white
okay you could actually push this pawn oh oh my
gosh is the car going to lose this this is what
you call you know when you get the tunnel vision
of like oh i can just do whatever i want a car
could lose this game here comes this king to the
other side of the board but bishop f8 that holds
no no he's not losing this that's just complete
draw so the point is that bishop f8 bishop c5
is going to be the move for the rest of the game
right bishop f8 bishop c5 nothing you can do
the problem with opposite colored bishops there's
light square bishop canon tackles pawn on b4
and we see just an easy draw
they'll play out forever
it is a draw for sure and there's a draw okay so
do we have any games left in this round we have a
few we have shigeru taking on demchenko and while
sugar was winning so that puts him a seven out of
nine and that puts him in striking distance you
need to be at eight and a half points when all
is said and done and at seven after nine of course
he can win his final game and make his way there
we have tourniquets and sunny kids with black down
a pawn against various of kovalev and this should
be a draw the point is that when you play g4 this
h pawn takes and then black just needs to sit the
king in the corner so the rook pawn is not good
in king and pawn end games without other pieces
remaining so that's the problem the rook pawn and
we saw it draw so heading into the final round we
will have eight people move on to the knockout
so far we have a five-way tie for first i expect
those players to do what they usually do and
make some quick draws and then all the way
down to 12th place is seven and a half points
so actually eight out of ten surprisingly has
a chance if you're sergey karjakin for example
you can potentially qualify for the knockout
but it's going to be relying on other people's
help right you need some results from others
and here we go so this game will be a draw in
five four three two one okay they actually have
to make the moves around the start but i expect
the game to end in a very quick draw let's see
and not yet at least not by mama jarv i have
not made a draw yet where's parham he's probably
already made a draw didn't he oh there we go a
two move draw how surprising and parham is playing
when do we think this draw will happen over under
10 moves so far it looks kind of like a fight
we have this uh approach here where you have the
good central control for white but black has the
bishop hair the bishop pair not exactly so useful
just yet especially this bishop on c8 tends to be
stuck behind pawns and white has given up a pawn
for the time being so you give up this d-pawn
you leave it there and you operate around it
oftentimes you want to try to put your bishop
back on b1 and get your queen to d3 not happening
here so queen came to e2 the rook will come to d1
and you'll try to go after the d-pawn in this
manner and the queen on e2 does a good job of
keeping the e5 pawn protected so you can move
your knight out the way and then protect e5
but just a normal looking position thus far i'm
going to tune out of this one i'm going to go to
kamsky nakamura what is this the us championship
of years past and hikaru has stole the b2 pawn
dropped the queen back to a3 and not good that
komski is spending quite a bit of time here
uh sorry one sec so uh yeah here are these
knights both of them pinned i guess and white
is trying to strike in the center while black's
king is stuck there so parham did draw his game
no surprises and this one looking
interesting let's go to more games here
peter spidler he needs to get to eight points
just to even have a chance at qualifying
his position is better with the black pieces but
we're not going to focus on this one for too long
let's focus more on the top games players fighting
for eight and a half we have pavel smirnov here
trying to take down shigeru swear with the black
pieces he has this interesting setup it's dynamic
with pauses a5 and b4 which can be weak later
in the game if i take on b4 and can pile up
pressure here but taking also opens up the a
file and a potential problem on the a4 square
so i think that both players are probably
sitting comfortably for now in this position
oh i'm i'm told i left hikaru against compsey
right when komsky blundered so i'm tuning back
and this is why i guess i shouldn't tune
away from games what happened here oh
my gosh the queen a4 forgetting about a
takes b5 and the rook protects the queen
you hate to see that if you're a komski fan or
if your komski himself and now he carries just
up a piece and completely winning so it's easy to
think that when you play this move queen a4 let's
go back in time again that this pawn is pinned
because it usually is when the rook is undefended
but the queen protects the rook through
white's queen and that's a free piece
so hikaru is going to win this game he is going
to move into the knockout bracket i'm sure
everybody's thrilled about that except for the
other participants they would have liked to see a
car on the outside and looking in so hikaru unless
something goes gravely wrong here and what could
even go wrong i'm trying to figure this out pawn
on d6 okay that's something that i can claim is
an advantage here so rook c1 please take me on d6
i'll take back with my knight your c5 knight will
hang and i could see a future if black isn't
careful where white starts winning the a pawn
start liquidating could have chances to hold
sonny this king is very happy to be sitting on
e8 and knight e4 is met by rook to beast
not rook b7 rook to b6 d7 what's that about
okay so rook d8 rook b7 bishop e7 knight c6
getting a little tricky get an old triggy
rook b7 there is knight to d6 as well which
attacks the rook and defends f7 that's good
and also protects the c8 square so if you want
to play rook c8 your rook is defended back here
so f6 is a possibility and was just played knight
c6 rook c8 pinning this knight down to the rook
it's all happening and after rook save the thread
is knight to b5 because knight b5 attacks the rook
and also threatens knight d4 check exploiting
the fact that the knight in c6 is pinned
to the rook on c1 so it looks like all variations
favor hikaru here and gotta he has to hope
it looks like a pipe dream at this
point and knight d4 check still
what a car is aiming for so king d3
makes sense knight e7 forcing things off
and once you trade everything on c6 you have king
d7 at the end and that's that teeny 7 actually was
probably possible right away but this is just
simple here bishop d6 drop the bishop to c7
what are you doing you're losing the
sword comes to a8 wins the a4 pawn
you can also bring the rook to b8 to just trade
the rooks off because the bishop and pawns vs
king upon ending his winning so rook b8 probably
just does the trick he plays rook eight smart
okay so hikar's gonna win this let's go back to
shigeru against smirnov what's happening here
still locked up position on the queen
side you take on a4 at any point but
after b takes a4 that could be a
potential issue it's even material
rook a3 what a move what a move oh my
gosh rook a3 just planting the rook
uh there what a concept just putting the
rook here so you know a queen a7 and you
could take with the pawn and have an
outside pass pawn that is something
wow wow wow i mean just taking over the
board rook a1 here comes bishop f1 check
my gosh so let's see how to finish this game
though i need to get my queen involved and
i'm looking at queen over to h5 so
he plays g5 first if you take on g5
h takes hx in comes the queen to h7 that
would just result in a checkmating attack
would be disaster f5 played reinforcing uh the
square here now queen f7 threatens queen f3
but queen f7 queen h5 is also good it looks
like smirnov isn't taking this one home bishop
f1 queen entry is made bishop one and queen h3 is
checkmate queen she's still is checkmate because
you're going into g2 and otherwise bishop any
where's the bishop go bishop d3 and made on f1
damn that was a cruncher crush let's go
back to karjakin he has no time left but his
position looks pretty good and i'm looking at the
standings eight out of ten right now he's tied for
sixth place oh my gosh kayaking lost in time
so liam vrolick is actually the one who could
potentially sneak in the field eight out of
ten karjatkins chances of making the speeches
championship through the grand prix they're gone
and let's look at vivid against kuzabov what's
happening here vidit pushing his pawn going
to eight and a half points yes sir and take
on a5 move the knight back a5 don't go a6 don't
pre-move a6 by king b7 and then the rest is easy
faded gujarati at eight and a half points let's
see it i mean somehow he lost pace with the
leaders and he's trying to beat uh fanduerine
van der reen i don't know i pronounced his
username but that's mexican shigayev who was
closing in on the fourth qualification spot
from the sec gp he would have to win this game
and do well in the knockout that's not happening
he loses on time and it's a mean time to buy
who gets the victory so let's see eight and
a half points that's it nope nobody else is
making it in it looks like the field is set
with the eight and a half point performances
and let me just check to see if there are other
games remaining they probably are but they don't
affect anything yeah they're down to six now point
territory winning position knight g4 knight f2
and that allows the h1 to promote
so 89 points it's what was needed so
for kayaking even though he lost that final game
meant nothing couldn't make it through anyway and
wow what a field we have we have parham
ponzilaya who's alex sir i haven't checked yet
somebody tell me who alex sir is i can try
to look myself just so much effort you know
try to figure out who alex sir is now
that's a zero chess i don't want you i want
alex sir
who are you let's see oh federation
okay very strong russian grandmaster
so i think the field is set and with that being
the case going to take a break so we can set
everybody up in the knockout when we return it
will be elimination time and we know our field
so get excited hikara nakamura everyone's going to
be trying to knock him out but he is an absolute
force to be reckoned with week after week be
right back everyone patience is not a virtue
it is a weapon
what's your wow rabbit
so
and we do have an upcoming speeches championship
invitational you can see the prize in front of you
first place being 1250 which is not a bad payday
in addition to qualifying for the main speeches
championship follow chess.com social media
and news reports to find out more information
when it gets confirmed but that will be a great
event featuring eight players vying for a spot
in the scc and speaking of vying for a spawn in
the sec i imagine that our players from the grand
prix are just about locked in because those
that were on the outside looking in i don't
think they've made their way to the knockout so
we'll have to get verification whether hike marty
rosen's standing is confirmed because he was in
fourth place but not participating today would
be interesting to note how that finishes off but
we do have our eight participants for the knockout
today uh parham maxoudlu ends up in first place
he gets the one seed and he takes on alexander
ingesh who is the eighth seed so it's going to
be interesting to see all of these grandmaster
on grandmaster battles here no easy matches none
whatsoever it's never going to be the case when
you're qualifying via the swiss part of the scc
here the gps are just so tough and hikaru nakamura
locked in at the fourth seed he faces levon
panzulaya and if he can beat uh that opponent
in the opening round then he'll likely face oppar
muksudo so you see in front of you all matches
they're the fan favorite vita gujarati he's the
seventh seed the opposite side of the bracket
from mikara nakamura and the uh he faced the two
seat alexey pre uh roshini and shakur mama jarov
come on needs no introduction there one of the
best players in the world for the last decade he
takes on pavel smirnov and smirnov has been doing
quite well in recent events it seems like he's
really getting the hang of these online
formats so very strong player from russia
let me just make sure that i
am following all these players
don't want to miss any of the action of course
so you know we just make sure that when it starts
i'll be ready and thus far i feel pretty ready for
these matches what say you chat what do you think
about these match-ups i'm sure everyone thinks
hikaru is the favorite hard to argue with that
but some of the others may not be so clear so what
do you see as the final matchup today i'm curious
your thoughts do you think it's going to be
hikara versus mama jarov is mama jarv going
to be knocked out along the way i don't know how
could i be certain all these players are so strong
all i know for certain is i want the action
to continue because i love these speeches
championship tournaments so fun quick pace a lot a
lot to cover all due start at once that is correct
car reverse nakamura exactly the
car see a lot of video fans here
no surprise vitidopi where's samaya
is he commentating on the action
but yeah we do have the format in front of you
is a three plus one time control as has been
the case uh throughout this scc gp and then if
they draw their game it goes to a bullet game so
knockover's vidit would be height
yeah that would be pretty cool but i don't know
hikara is the first round matchup that is no
walk in the park that's for sure levon panzerlaya
very tough competitor vita gujarati also i mean
he's facing tough player after tough play on
his side of the bracket so i would say that
no player is in the clear i mean para maksublu
beat hikaru nakamura so we say hikaru should
be the favorite but parham already beat him once
today and as he is the number one seed he'll get
good odds against hikaru
so i'm glad you're enjoying the commentary
i really hope that's the case so
just trying to figure out when these
games begin so i can continue commentating
and stop trying to force you all to make
predictions okay the games are about to start
so i'm getting word of and well i'm
excited for them here we see the game
e4 no it plays c4 we get the english opening
instead and these are three minute plus one
second increment time controls it's going
to be hard to flag any of these players as
they get that second edge of their clock
after every move and h5 alpha zero style
we'll see if engine is really trying to push
that pawn forward or if it's just a starting move
and his knight will come to h6 and f5 is a
typical plan here but parham ready to play
the other side of the board with b4 challenging
black's queen side so i'm not sure about this
voluntarily inducing a h3 and the knight on c3 is
not defended so b4 would be a blunder of course
but you can play bishop d2 first and then play
b4 so i'm not sure that this actually helps black
and let's go on to hikara versus
ponzulaya oops we uh see that he is
on the white side of this position he has control
of the d5 square and we'll try to use the light
scores to his advantage that is what is typical
in these sort of night or type positions it's not
a night or it was a con but you see this pawn
on d6 so you want to cement that pawn in place
and go after it so let's see here so the bishop
one c5 so far is defending that pawn but you can
play b4 bring this knight into c4 and then it
can be white as the aggressor in this position
so let's uh keep on moving we'll go to vidit's
game against me as that one is taking place
and look at this opening we have a king's gamut
you don't see that every day but vidit plays e5
and prederogane plays f4 and bobby fischer
must be very happy in his grave to see this
because it is an adventurous opening the pawn f4
is going to be recaptured unless black tries a
knight h5 type move and said knight to e5 please
take me on e5 help my pawn structure so that e5
is attached to f4 instead he drops the bishop
back and you can play move like bishop to g4
the point being that hey like let me pin your
knight and take it and force you to take with
your g pawn but white will recoup the pawn on
f4 which is why knight g6 was played instead by
bidding that it is down quite a lot of time here
so he's moving slowly but accurately and according
to the evaluation bar off the side of the screen
here is liking this position slightly but that
can quickly turn around especially if this king
doesn't get itself castled in the near future
so so far interesting games all across
them let's go back to the parham game
against ingish and knight d5 was just played so
before we get back i just want to see the next
two moves here because black has safely
castled this pawn is now defended on f4
and how is white actually going to get that pawn
back that's a tough question to answer black could
play c6 to kick this bishop out from d5 you could
also play bishop e6 and please take me on e6 fix
my pawn structure and f4 is well defended
for the time being not a big fan of white's
position but parham he's in the midst of his game
against indic somehow black's pawn structure has
become i double pawns the f-file and we see what
happened was in the last couple moves this knight
went d5 e3 and just chopped the bishop down so
thank you for your bishop you know take back with
your pawn good for you and now you have a weak
f5 point you have this pawn on b7 if you ever you
take on d3 the diagonal opens up queen a4 comes
to mind in the near future as well this is looking
very sharp and that is a very bad sign for engish
because white is the one with the bishop pair so
c5 is immediately hanging queen f4 on the docket
f5 permanent weakness b file open every single
aspect of this position favors white including
time right now so it looks like parham is cruising
in this game i'd be very shocked if he doesn't
win this game it looks so easy for him to play
so let's keep on going here hikaru nakamura
against levon ponculia i mentioned this pawn
on d6 earlier it remains there but lavon
doing a very good job of coming after these
c the c pawn using the c file to his advantage
but uh oh there is a vulnerable f5 square here
that looks like a problem what is the knight in f8
doing where is it going you need to cover this f5
square i imagine and so the knight back on e6 so
that when the knight gets to f5 you drop your king
and bring your knight to g7 off of the trade and
then e6 would offer a trade in both directions
if the knight came to d5 you put the knight on c7
if the knight came to f5 you put the knight on g7
but then f8 does absolutely nothing for black's
position i don't think you have time to like
queen e6 knight d7 knight f6 things like that it
seems too slow and 93 is still possible i imagine
because 93 rookie 4 i could probably queen f3
and your rook is likely getting trapped in the
center of the board so i would be concerned
about black's position here that's for sure
queen f3 comes to mind he does play
knight to e3 tactically saying this pawn
is sort of immune from capture and i have
received word that mama jarv wins by forfeit
his opponent just went offline and didn't come
back so mama jarv moves on to the semi-finals
and okay so rook c6 played wait queen
takes e5 check wasn't that a free pawn
oh gotta go back queen e5 d-e oh wait look
at me miss cal king there's a knight there
protecting so i'm blundering pieces that are
not mine typical me and instead the queen came
up to g4 hitting the h5 pawn this some potential
for black to come back here rook takes d6 though
do not take on c6 next because that hangs d1
with check so that's why knight g6 was played
take me i dare you not so fast d1 is hanging so
you will not take on c6 instead i could see a move
like king g2 potentially play but then queen
g4 is quite a nuisance throwing knight f4 and
pinning the g3 pawn so just need to be a little
bit accurate here that's all that's required as
a mattress queen e4 is played g4 queen moves rook
takes g6 could that have been something to open up
the black king and g4 there's queen h3 that
holds on for now trying to figure out that like
finishing touch that's what i'm looking for
here can i take on b7 and bring the next work in
i can take mb7 this way but knight f4 is the
idea it feels like that kind of move even if
it should not work out it has the potential to
cause some problems so the rook backs up to f6
and okay i thought maybe rook to
d6 and trading the rooks training
feels like a good plan so rook f3 also
would trade rooks but there's knight f4
okay trading rooks from b6 makes sense and the car
looks like he's going to win this game so we're
going to move on from ikaro's game go back to some
of the others parham has two minor pieces for the
rook he is in fact just crushing uh engish in
this game this pawn on f5 very strong don't play
f6 because that walks into rook f5 rook takes
f6 okay he does it but i guess there's rook f3
so it does work out for parham nonetheless can't
stop pawn f7 and this also can capture on b6
the a takes v6 i think that black is frozen over
there but why not just take a rook for a night
when you can take on h5 move your bishop back to
e8 h pawn promotes game over so hikaru did win his
game let's go to the vidic game because that's
in a rook end game that's much more interesting
much more life left as we just see parham
win this one we have project against vidit
is up two pawns in this end game so he can just
go king to b4 now okay king b6 keeping his pawns
safe and sound brook takes h3 that's
three extra pawns per video he has 10
seconds to one and he wins the game so the
quarterfinals i mean they wrapped up pretty
quickly there so we're going to take another
quick break and we're going to make sure that
everything is set for the semi-finals and
when we return we will see parham against
hikaru and vita gujarati against mohammed
europe you will not want to miss the action
and we have two players in the semi-finals
this is taking on hikaru nakamura
it is in the top side of the bracket parham
the one seed hikara d4 they'll be playing
a best of two little mini match here in the
three plus one time control if there's a tie
they go to bullet and the first winner in the
bullet wins the match up so the games um we'll
start in about 30 seconds i'm being told
so just uh hold on for a quick second there
and we will get this matchup going and parham he
did defeat ekkar nakamura in the swiss portion
of the event hikaru is obviously a tremendous
player and just because he lost once earlier
he in fact might be angry about that
and will look to seek his revenge
so we're just waiting for the game to start any
second now and parham he did choose black to start
he has the higher seed he gets to choose color
and we have game in motion so we have a spanish
we've seen this from the car a lot and we saw
it earlier today in their match and hirocarp is
knight to d2 so you have to watch out to make
sure the e5 pawn isn't falling and typically
there are queen d4 type of tricks but parham says
let me just make sure that i'm not driving upon
ever queen e7 defends don't be playing bishop
e6 or something like that to drop the pawn so um
so let's see and is the first game of the
semifinals here so knight c4 okay this is
very typical you're going after the e5 pawn black
retrieves the knight to d7 so you can play f6 or
even f5 depending on how white continues his
approach here because if you castle and can
play f5 that does harm your e5 palm maybe creates
a nice little pawn but there are times when that
is worth it so first you probably want to develop
make sure everything is connected and safe and
sound before ever making move like f5 and you're
not getting f5 because hikaru was trying to fill
the square with his knight and we saw him do this
earlier this knight came out to b6 so that when
knight f5 happened parham took on that square
but this time he plays knight to f8 so he's not
going to take on f5 i don't think he'll first move
his queen away to f7 unless you can just take on
f5 and i saw the evaluation for a jump so
perhaps there was some kind of bishop takes f5
and queen to d7 for example but
instead we have seen a trait on e3
and now f takes e3 this knight can come
to e7 this knight can try to come to h4
maybe like a slight little pull but
it doesn't feel like there's anything
major happening just yet so hikaru on the white
side this position hasn't obtained all that much
if you play d4 you have to watch about the
e4 pawn so first card drops the knight back
to d2 opens up the f file maybe trying to
react the knight over to the queen side so
where can you go for this knight nowhere the
bishop can capture it no matter where it goes
and this knight can come back to e7 to challenge
the knight f5 so it's just a game of tense
repositioning and i just don't see how
either side is planned to make progress
anytime soon a car tripling on the f file but
what next you know is he gonna play g4 h4 h5
oh that was a committal decision by parham i don't
like his decision at all this queen can actually
snake into the queen side at
some point obviously g5 is
what's coming up soon rook g2 g5 knight to e4 i
don't like what parham did there take out f5 felt
not just premature just actually wrong and he's
interpreted knight on d6 and here comes pawn to
e4 protecting f5 another time getting g5 ready
so it wasn't just about placing a knight on e4
which is probably good but now it's at the
pawn me4 and black is very restricted here
and the side that controls the pawn breaks is
often the side of the advantage here it's clear
white controls the pawn breaks with pawn and g5
and king h2 over g1 pawn g5 so is black one played
b5 very risky decision no he plays g5 hoping to
shut down the initiative that's happening on this
flank but that looks super risky he car smartly
takes on poisson opens up the f line this pawn
here h5 or g5 both moves you have to keep an eye
out on g5 mail out f5 so probably not so fast on
that one but i'm sorry i clicked that square
that was not hikara that was me but queen e3
and this rook can slide up to f3 and maybe
even over to the h file depending on what's
happening here not a fan of parliament's
position and the card doing very well on
the clock he's nearly two minutes two pounds
minute and fifteen seconds so what can you do
you probably have to defend quite passively
for the time being h5 still a possibility
you have to think about the repercussions
of if the pawn charger gets locked up h5 g5
now h5 there's knight g5 so that's actually
a very good square for the knight to get to
because the knight wants to get to e6 and into f4
so g5 is just step one as i reposition the knight
to f4 so knight otherwise come in d8 e6 and d4
and f4 are available so actually i'm starting
to appreciate black's position a bit more now as
parham he's making it happen here comes the knight
and i don't know where he cards it has to be on
d5 before that night gets to f4 but you don't have
time for it 96 you can't play knight jumping into
the d5 square and times like queen f2 knight e6 93
you're a step behind so knight g3 is their knight
of five that's the big question here is their
knight f5 and i guess the knight of five you can
just move your queen to h7 do not play queen to
f7 because that would walk into knight h6 with a
check and a fork so instead the knight comes back
over to e2 and is it time for the king run is
it time to dart that king over to the queen side
i think so i don't like my king here i also like
getting my rook to h8 and hitting the h4 pawn
so i think it's time to play king f7 not an
easy move to play usually but here i see my
rook on f8 doing a good job of defending f6 so
my king going that way it does make sense g5
clearly trying to get this knight into f4
and we see a capture and now pawn takes
oh this looks problematic though this looks not
so good for black you don't want to take on f5
because then you stay with either pawn honestly
so you're trying to keep the position as close as
possible but it feels like white's pieces are just
a little bit more active rook h6 can be met by
can i go knight h5 because you take with the
knight the g5 pawn hangs oh my gosh there's a
lot to calculate really a ton here i have
the feeling that black should be okay but
kind of walking on eggshells and he needs a
move he plays rook h6 ultimately i think is a
good choice knight h5 takes as i mentioned the g5
pawns hanging rook takes g5 take it and then rook
g6 you take this rook on uh h5 and it protects
the g5 rook so i think you're getting away with
it but there is rook four at the end of this
it's not as easy as i initially made it seem and
brooke g5 rook g6 rook h5 rook f4 trying to close
this queen off in the defense of the g5 square
it's becoming really intense in this position
so he takes with the pawn on h5 the knight takes
h5 so he got pre-moved and i guess the claim
is that e5 and g5 are weaker than f5 and h5
so king h7 queen e4 maybe just to threaten
f6 check the queen blockades but the queen
doesn't want to sit on f6 queens are notoriously
bad block haters so this pawn is hanging on e5
so trades okay but this c7 pawn is a big problem
but if rook h2 rook at e7 rook h7 rookie seven
uh-oh black lily's surviving he gets his king
to walk back here so rook f7 now go after the f5
point rook g7 okay king f8 also works i guess
because the king can just start marching up
well that was a good move though f6
and rook h7 found so quickly by parham
take this and it should almost certainly be
close to a draw but i would be careful if i
were hikaru because if this king somehow can
oh candy five rookie four very important move
because if that king could get to d4 all of a
sudden it's black who's trying to win this game
so yeah this is just a draw at this point
so draw a greed parham once
again with the black pieces
staves off any sort of pressure that hikaru
nakamura brings him he won the first game he
drew this one and now parham gets white
the issue for parham is that in bullet
obviously hikaru has to be the favorite it's
just first to win a gaming bullet so not so
easy to say that icar will definitively win that
but he is a bullet machine and in blitz well
hikaru should be the favorite here too but
parham's been playing a really nice day of chess
all right so knight to g5 this is typical berlin
situation here um the knight captured on e6 you
take back with the pawn not a big deal but here
the knight came to d4 and i think parham has to
be a little bit careful knight takes e6 you can
take with the f pawn and i was mentioning that's
perfectly fine for black often it's actually
helpful you get yourself a semi open f file this
pawn e5 is one that has over extended itself in
many variations so i do think that we will see 96
because rook to c1 is met by bishop f5 and that's
going for the c2 pawn so i think it now is the
time to play knight takes e6 get rid of the bishop
pair and maybe you're not in an advantageous
position but you just say you know they got to do
what i got to do so knight caption e6 to keep the
pawn shutter attack g6 stops f5 if you play g4
i welcome the opening of the h file so it says
g3 first that was king g2 king f3 and bench you
play for g4 if you did not play g3 black would
have played h4 so that you could ah you could
take on poisson if that pawn ever tries to move
someone said g3 is played so h4 is met with g4
don't be playing h4 that just helps white out and
here bishop c3 pawn 63 the claim is that you've
double isolated my queen side pawns not that big a
deal my king side paw majority is more important
because you have isolated not excuse me double
pawns of your own this is the maximum sheila grav
treatment of this opening we've seen in players
a number of times and doubling isolating your own
pawns i guess is not the most important thing here
so here we see here i should say the sirens
likely for the pawn structure to be and the
car was thinking before playing will he take on
c3 will he bring his king up to e7 to connect
the rooks so that one of them can go to the
d8 square will they start with rook to d8
looks like a very good and natural move it's just
all coming down to his decision making is he going
to take on c3 and we see hikaru grabbing his
head deep in thought there trying to figure out
he plays f5 what a concept it shuts down g4 it
says if you do not take me on poisson which you
can only do right now and that's what harm does
if you do not do that the structure gets shut down
and the knight in the light square shows the issue
with the bishop of dark scores the knight can't
be kicked out but here bishop d4 will probably
force off a trade and then the f6 pawn hangs at
the end there so it's just a series of trades that
should still be beneficial for white because then
i've just plugged my rook on the e5 square i know
that's a lot to visualize but if you can imagine
a capture on d4 the pawn gets here you've just
actually helped my rook stabilize on the e5 square
so the rook is coming to e4 that's the idea
and this rook is coming to e8 do not take
on h f6 excuse me take out 6 would be a
big mistake because you're walking into
a discovery this 96 needed to be defended first
okay so how to push 40 you can play g4 at
now or any moment um i okay g4 was played
you better be careful because g5 would
protect that past pawn and if king f6
is there anything here like if i move my bishop
to h4 that looks like a normal decision to get
the bishop out there okay brings his king in
first maybe he'll play king f3 and then bishop to
f2 but i want to get my bishop to h4 because by
having the bishop on h4 you're pinning the knight
in a way because the rook could come to e7 if this
bishop were on h4 so just trying to reposition
improve the location of that bishop first
but as we see here hikaru has handled this
very well expertly and i don't think that
black is worse in fact i'd probably take
black based on the pawn structure on the queen
side one issue is that if you want to actually
make progress you would love somehow to get your
rooks like a6 or a5 but your pawns are in your way
so king f3 taking back on for the k is the king
trying to get all the way up here that seems too
risky so if takes takes brook replaces rook
on e8 is the king going to d5 it's possible
certainly possible i just
don't like walking into pins
although bishop can retreat and offer an
exchange of rooks so maybe it's not so bad
so hickory thinking here he does
take he'll play rookie a check
and maybe king f3 so you can play rook
h1 next and try to free up your rook
he plays it there's nowhere from black
to infiltrate right d2 is covered by
this bish 23 king g3 now okay bishop two saying
similar here you can't get in but if knight e6
it's not threatening anything like has the
look of a good move and it's played but bishop
g3 and watch out for f5 do not blunder f5 with
bishop e5 check so his rook h7 very smart move
now is he preemptively defending the c7 pawn
he's saying if you play f5 and check me here
so what my rook is no longer on the h8
square which would have been a problem
and if you're swinging rook to d1 same issue
you can't get in there's nowhere to get in the
position so rook e5 trying to play f5 that's a
good try k plays f5 now knight g5 check there's
king even king f4 there and i would have to go
to h3 and that knight does not want to be on h3
you could play king e3 as well
it's a matter of taste i guess but
otherwise where's his knight going takes you take
with a rook don't want to lie that maybe knight g7
just trying to take on f5 and not like two
with the rook so it plays in that g5 check
king e3 right away okay i would have thought
of putting the king on f4 first rook f5 kg6
and bishop f4 bishop h4 my bishop h4 i don't
want to allow bishop 496 attacking the bishop
even though black cannot afford to trade minor
pieces often because now i have an extra pawn
on the king side and all the other pawns
are on the queen side but bishop h4 knight
h7 maybe just to defend the f6 square i
don't really like the look of knight h7
so playing that f7 saying i don't care
about rook check let's just one check
okay king f4 g5 all right you didn't want to
bring the king up if you bring the king up too
far then the rook start starts coming down
or knight d6 and i don't think you want to
allow a rook trade if you live work trade
the king will block on the light square
here comes the rook for the pawn so king g4
bishop e5 that's what i want to accomplish here
so takes bishop e5 there's knight c4 maybe
wait can i take on d6 oh so writes up a pawn
check here takes takes i think we're
liquidating rook f2 check oh oh now this
okay so this is going to be tough
a4 c4 check oh that's immediately
wait can you have five and that's the drum
you have the six rank defense just rook a6 now
yeah it's a drug parham was really trying gear
he was pressing him couldn't make it work though
and they make a draw so we're about to
have a bullet game between these two
and wow that was i mean this moment here with
a4 i guess that was a mistake and probably rook
a6 or something like that just keeping the pawn
protected was a better way to try and win the
game but black likely would have just pushed the
pawn down like move the rook push the pawn and
eventually it probably was just going to end in
a draw anyway so nice try there by parham hikaru
did show some great defense and parham now has to
take him down a bullet here we go i'll try to be
useful while they're playing
bullet chess all right
so symmetrical structure 97 so you can play c5 in
the near future he puts knight to b6 stopping c4
so instead of playing 4c5 this is a pure bullet
game no increment here so c4 good setup so far
for parham and good time management for hikaru all
right a4 so you can play a5 and maybe even a6 to
try to get at this pawn on c6 so a5 a6 still
on the docket here and a car is moving quite
slowly considering his typical speed c3
nice move you don't allow the pawn to
get on c34 and try to keep the pawns together
now this is a target here but e3 is coming so
there's also a6 coming so if c5 is a6
you have to be very careful about that
and h4 seemed a little irrelevant okay h5 not
sure where his pawn's going here because e4 was
never working because the d4 pawn would have
fallen and i think you take this at some point
you consider taking on e5 because if you get this
double pawn it can blockade the situation then
uh this can turn around very quickly the knight
can be better than bishop but rook c2 is something
that one needs to be careful about i still don't
like the look of bishop takes e5 that's why i went
knight to d3 they're very smart by parham but he's
down 10 seconds here no no he car is way too fast
how in the world can he can he hold this game
his position is fine objectively but now it's
about the clock bishop a3 bishop takes d6
oh my gosh we should be five he won a piece
oh no he didn't he won and said the queen
for uh two rooks and can you find 95 97.
he said take us but hit cars too much time
here so it should be totally fine for white
or maybe black's going to have blacks winning
is winning on the board and on the clock
bishop a3 rook c6 for c1 that's game over
take take bring the rook back around somehow
bishop e5 is possible c4 check can't take on b2
after rooks before his car was too good the car
was way too good what a beast what an absolute
monster there wasn't a moment there where i saw
the evaluation bar jump so let's go to that moment
i know that parham didn't have too much time
so bishop d6 rook c1 bishop e5 didn't like
so it wasn't just like rooksy one rook d6 and
i guess some kind of it's kind of like rook c7
or something you know this is a positional way of
going for a win here looks good it's hard to play
with no time in your closet just when you see
bishop e5 you go for that the tactical sequence
you're down a lot it car was 33 53 in bullet chest
oh boy that's uh that's pretty high pretty
high so anyway this didn't happen this indeed
instead did and parham was able to
net himself this rook for his knight
but now black has a rook a bishop and a pawn
for the queen that's lasker compensation
and you're never going to survive against a
car when you have nine seconds left so yeah
by the way mama jarv has chosen the black pieces
to start his match against avid gujarati so mama
jarov takes the black pieces this is typical in
high level play in a two game little mini match
starting with black so you know what you need with
white so if you lose the game with black you say
let me take a more aggressive approach give myself
more winning chances if you win the game with
black you can just take a calmer approach maybe
try to find a forcing sequence and if you draw
well you get the white pieces you can do what you
want okay we're about to have go time here between
uh gujarati and mamanjaro so as soon
as that game begins i will pull it up
so almost there almost ready and
as mentioned mama jarv starts with
the black pieces he made his way to the
semi-finals his opponent just didn't even
show up in the quarterfinals he didn't know
about the knockout portion of things that
was pavel smirnov but either way mama jarov
deserving participant here in the final four
and we have a game
so bitter choose d4 no surprise that is his main
weapon and will we get a king's indian when we get
a grunfeld the answer is in front of us we have
a grunfeld we were talking about peters fiddler
earlier he is a renowned grunfeld theoretician and
won the world's if not the world's leading expert
on the grunfeld the point for black is you've
given up control over the center in the sense
of the pawn placement white has an additional pawn
in the center compared to blacks one but look at
how quickly you can apply pressure on that center
and in the end game once we trade on d4 i have a
two on one majority for black so central control
in white's favor the end game the two on one
all the way on the queenside flank over there
is beneficial for black but it doesn't make
its relevance felt for quite a bit of
time because look at white's rook on c1
it's can land on c7 at some moment the d4 and
e4 pawns are still very strong restricting for
example this bishop on c8 it goes to e6 thank you
i go to d5 i just kick your bishop back so black's
pieces don't exactly have the nicest squares to
go to knight c6 can be met by d5 at some point so
that's why the pawns in the center are good your
pieces belong in the center pawns are restricting
your pieces that's that so if i'm playing as mama
jarv here i'm trying to figure out not just a
move but a plan he plays knight c6 here comes
d5 and then i believe the knight should go to
okay let's say e5 it goes to b4 going after this
pawn but wait a sec that knight's not getting out
if you take on a2 rook c2 happens and your
knight gets trapped on a2 so this looks like a
mistake by mama jarv we have him on
camera i'm looking at his reaction there
then it looks like he's like under a onesie
or something he looks so cozy there and
he's just hanging out and mamadiarov is looking
quite stressed and well you don't want to go 96
i think that it can take it on a6 instead plays
knight a5 first trying to take on a6 plug that
knight on c6 so things still looking good for vita
gujarati and both these players above twenty seven
hundred feet of course mama jar have been a top
ten fifteen you know he goes up to number two in
the world and back down to say number fifteen i'm
not sure of his exact rating at this moment but
he's been an elite player for over a decade and
for vita gujarati he's you know making his way
up there he's obviously very very strong
he captained the indian team at the
online olympiad and he's played many events this
summer but he hasn't quite made it to that 2750
level that's not a criticism it's just fact so
we're looking for vida to make that push when
more over-the-board chess resumes you know when
the pandemic hopefully subsides then we'll see if
he's able to make his way up even more but right
now he has a great position with white pieces he's
up a minute and 20 seconds on the clock so he
understands these positions extremely well and
mama jarvis is struggling because now if you play
e6 i can probably take you the bishop can't take
back because the pawn on b7 needs a defender so
b6 played in comes the knights of c6 very quickly
and this rook will go to d7 it's not the end
of the world for mama jarv it doesn't look
awesome but it looks okay he's just trying
to hold down the fort for the time being
here it comes and this knight can try to
come to c5 to put pressure on the e4 pawn
looks like a standard plan of action bishop e3
saying you're not getting a c5 without recapturing
you and that also makes sense because if i
can steal a pawn even if you have compensation
you need to prove that it's sufficient for
equality because con compensation excuse me is
the term that sometimes doesn't amount to what
you may think it does this rook on a8 is a bit
stuck the a7 pawn can be hanging in many
variations so i would be worried about that
bishop c6 does not look good no matter the line
you would take hitting the rook but this knight is
also a problem so can i play knight d4 96 check
no because you can take on d4 with your bishop
i wanted to you're not you're assuming your
rook is protected on c7 i wanted to like
reroute this knight really quickly and that
would be good under other circumstances but
it doesn't quite work out maybe it's fine to trade
on d4 square but it's not quite what i wanted and
thinking here he has plenty of time to
do so up about um 50 seconds on the clock
how to make progress bishop f4
comes to mind hitting this rook here
uh what else the reason i don't like bishop f4
is it takes away your control of c5 square but
maybe that's worth it you can take on f5 g takes
play bishop d3 and just swing your attention to
this king side that looks pretty interesting
but whenever you take on f5 or push upon
e5 the d5 pawn becomes a little bit looser
so you do have to think about that as well
but i'm looking at e takes a five
now so it's catching my attention
it looks like a good chance to net
a pawn if you are a bit of gujarati
there is a one second increment this time which
was three minute plus one second increment
and vid it using so much of his time he does
take on f5 and mama jarv had that pre-moved
he knew that was happening and he plays knight
to d4 but now isn't this d5 pawn just hanging
so okay it's not actually hanging yet because
the 986 is under attack okay so for the time
being that it has it under control but if rook
c7 knight c7 then the pawn excuse me the pawn
here is really a problem the bishop and the
knight atlanta c7 are both teaming up on it
so bishop d3 he takes his attention this way he
took the rook on c7 that's interesting because
the bishop can't take on d5 the knight a6 is
hanging knight to b4 drops the pawn to f5 and h7
is hanging after that so what white really wants
is i'll take f5 and then push the pawns but here
now this rook is captured on d5 would hit
the bishop on f5 and the bishop one d4
bishop takes f5 so you have to be careful here
you have to be careful rook once was rook d5
oh [ __ ] 56 he plundered it and bishop g7 check
a huge blunder by mama jarov he loses an exchange
you tip the knight on a6 to distract the bishop
away and now after rook d7 e7 and a7 were in tech
take here and rook b7 and vidic winning this
game fitted gujarati is winning thanks to a
huge miscalculation by mom and jarv when they're
rooks in a row you have to be very careful and
maybe i'm speaking too soon is it quite winning b3
king e3 you get your king here first and then put
your rook on b7 so i think you are in time to play
king e3 here you go bring the king closer you also
play f4 check if you need to and get your rook
on over to b7 f4 check okay bring king d2 first
i like putting the pawn on dark square and that's
why mama jarva is trying for some kind of bishop
one but rook g7 does the trick and after rook g7
the h pawn roams it frolicks to the other side
wow what a one move turn around there i mean
brook takes d5 right here just not recognizing
the danger of rooks in a row so vidit gets the
black pieces oh mama jarv ran away where'd he go
he's back
i don't know if he realized the game was
starting so quickly but vidit takes that one
and now with the black pieces mama jared playing
this variation with the queen drops back to d3
okay and the bishop can drop in on the g5
square or d2 i don't know these lines really
that well and hence why i'm saying moves like
bishop to g5 it looks like a normal move but
there probably are some tactics by taking
on c3 on e4 the bishop run g5 so knight e2
all right so white's position is very compact here
i think f3 makes sense keep everything in a line
instead he plays bishop g5 h6 the bishop drops
back to h4 the knight on e2 protects the other
knight so bishop c3 queen c3 then knight takes c4
would make sense but you can take back on c3 with
the knight and this knight to e5 then bring the
knights to g6 it feels like a very vivid type of
maneuver so i wouldn't be looking at that but
they need to watch out for bishop takes f6 and
knight to d5 at some point because that would hit
the queen and the bishop at the same time but of
course the queen on d3 was under attack first okay
knight d5 coming watch out c6 a possibility here
takes takes knight g6 and if knight d5
is knight takes e4 tactics everywhere
in such a position but vidiq says i'm not
forcing anything i'm going to be com play c6
um knight g6 will get this bishop off the board
but now the d6 pawn is weaker the bishop does
cover it for the time being but you have to
keep an eye on that i think a3 makes a lot
of sense because either black takes on c3 or
plays bishop a5 but in either way the d6 pawn
becomes more of a target so i think that mama
jarv is doing the right thing and f4 knight g6 e5
getting hectic over here but i don't think it
actually works out because f3 instead uh just
to show very quickly f4 here e5 you can make use
of the pin but knight h4 ef6 is the movie you
want to play but there's queen takes f6 and i'm
protecting my knight so that wouldn't work out
so instead f3 was played and for vidit he needs to
find a move here knight g6 does hang this pawn on
d6 was just talking about that that doesn't
look good suppose queen e7 so now if knight
g6 and you take on d6 i will be able to take on
h4 my queen isn't hanging in that variation but
there will be bishop f6 and then take on d6 but
as is usually the case the bishop pair that black
obtains gives good compensation so b5 protects
the c4 square if you want to jump there but also
clearly threatens to use the a3 as a hook to play
b4 open this position up but rook's coming to b8
and voila that's a quick attack so if i'm
mama jarv you should be very careful not even
to need to win this game so you have to figure out
a way to do that but i need to be careful not to
lose the game as well knight a2 just stopping
before a clear retreating move and i think it's
obvious now what he's trying to accomplish and
knight g6 comes to mind i know i'm hanging in d6
but i said maybe that's okay bishop c7 watch
out for d5 okay d5 you can just capture it
g5 does not pin this and obviously you're not
pin does not win this bishop on h4 because the
pawn is pinned to the king there may be
a sack right there or f4 you don't play
movie g5 unless you're a thousand percent
sure and then it won the first game of this
two game match so why should he risk it
with a movement g5 bishop d7 that allows
c5 in some variations but the pawn b5 is
still under attack because the bishop on
f1 is there but you may want to sacrifice this
pawn on b5 to open up the b file typical plan
so vidit he's bopping a little bit i think
he's stretching maybe dancing i'm not sure
either way he looks like he's in good shape
he's also up nearly 20 seconds on the clock
there's no way for white to easily
break through queen came back to f2
a5 looks pretty decent trying
to play for b4 and attack
knight g6 i've mentioned that move many times at
this point and knight h5 gets you the bishop he
plays a4 i like that move because knight before
was surprisingly annoying going after the c6 one
okay so h4 has been played trying
to go h5 bishop h4 get that pin back
he's in it to pin it where's dino diskey
and i said it only because it's vidit
but that has a tough one i have to be hard on
myself just like i am my co-commentators so h5 95
bishop h4 here comes some pressure is there a
g4 g5 happening anytime soon not so fast okay
but c5 now you give the b5 square so this
is not what vidit wanted and this pin is so
frustrating how do you deal with that maybe bishop
d he like a very sad retreating move because that
way you can move your queen out the way he instead
tries to take matters into his own hands with d5
and ed5 he can't take with the knight either stick
with the pawn give himself an isolated pawn this
bishop then gets the b5 square i'm not feeling
that i'm not feeling this one bit maybe bishop
b6 somehow keeps his knight on a2 out of play but
the knight is trying to reroute some to c1 to b3
so okay now the pin is gone so if you take
on the uh d7 i can take with this knife but
then knight f5 so be very careful you
do not want this knight landing on f5
especially if you can get into e7 next
with this knight on f6 captures back
and then f5 then promotes ideas like g4 and
just blasting through over here on the king side
this does not look good did it in more time
trouble than his opponent under pressure over the
board as well and queen b6 now if you take on b5
then i can still capture on b5 the bishop remains
for defends so that's not a good thing either
it feels like everything i say is beneficial for
mahmoud jarv and except for the clock he's down
at 16.5 seconds that's not good that's not good
at all and h5 can be captured at some point and
he captures it right now he has no fear he stole
the pawn and then i can come into f4 that looks
like a good decision here comes knight f4 right
now and then maybe the e knight can try to come
to g6 but you'd have to take on b5 first bishop b5
oh this that comes to c4 actually this is a
big issue in knight g2 we'll hit the bishop
and hit the rook here's knight c or knight f3
oh gosh i didn't even see that that's everything
everything is hanging and vidi is just mopping
up right now and he wins on time so gujarati
defeats mama's yard two to nothing and dang that
was a performance that was extremely impressive
we know our final match up it is hikaru nakamura
it is vita gujarati we're gonna take our final
break and when we return we will have the
matchup that everybody's been clamoring for
in the speeches championship grand
prix brought to you by chess.com
and you can see how these two super grandmasters
made their way to the final hikaru nakamura beat
levon panzolia then edged out paramag sulu
the top seed in a bullet game video gujarati
has been unscathed in the knockout beating alexey
pederojni and then sweeping chakra mamajara of a
bit of a surprise there mama jarov is a superstar
but in the first game it was getting to a position
towards the end game and well it looks like his
tactics were sharper in game two as well in the
time scramble it was vidit who looked like the
powerful player that he is and now he gets to face
as his reward hikaru nakamura for first place
in this knockout both these two players stellar
ambassadors of the game of chess been
streaming a ton lately made it on youtube
a car on twitch and we are just making
sure that the players are set up and
i'll be getting the word on who gets white in
the first game remember it is a two game mini
match of three minute plus one second increment
and um looks like hikaru is taking the white
pieces if i'm not mistaken so hopefully these
games take off soon and we'll get to the chess
because you know me i'm always excited for some
awesome speed chess great games to commentate on
and well that it is just looking to upset if you
will another super grandmaster back to back so
now it's hard to say in these uh online chess
events because vidit is a powerhouse himself
but mama jarov in terms of least over
the board chess has the higher of the two
ratings and ah i was wrong nick hickar has black
to start with so he gets black in the first game
and so vid it will try to prove the first move
advantage here try to take an initiative you do
not want to lose with the white pieces we saw you
know we've seen what happens in those cases you
lose the white and you somehow win with black not
so easy so for vidit you want to make the most of
this in the opening game and for hikaru well
you're kind of chilling we saw his approach
against parham xulu two draws are okay with
him because he is the favorite in the bullet
so we are going to have the games begin right
now here we are so bit it white pieces plays d4
we saw him do the same against mama jarv and will
we get a king's indian no we will not we will get
maybe a nimzo let's see how pita continues
here knight c3 typical bishop b4 after that
no we see knight f3 and d5 so we have the qgd
and we're going to get a catalan here we go the
bishop of the long diagonal please take me on c4
that's what has been asked and answered sure you
asked me to i will so this bishop on g2 would
love to remove that bishop on c6 out of the way
but the problem is not easy to do that you're not
going to accomplish that and this is the line i
believe where black takes an f3 and plays c6 so
you take on f3 the bishop takes back you play
c6 and you claim that you have a brick wall on
the queen side here it is exactly the sequence
and opposite color bishops white has slightly more
space but black has great control over this b4
square so that's the good news for black control
the b4 square no targets to exploit but white just
has more space and considering how quickly vid
has been playing this i feel like maybe he has a
little something up his sleeve here because black
generally speaking shuffles around a bit doesn't
really do much of anything you know if you place
you can't play c5 it opens up the bishop you can
think about playing e5 but that has ramifications
that you'll have to deal with as well so hikaru
i think we'll put a rook on d8 maybe f to d8 keep
this rook on a8 he plays e5 okay i thought d5 now
is the move because takes bishop takes and what
ideally you get is if this black knight takes
you on d5 you end up putting your own knight
on the light square and this bishop on d6 can't
attack you that's exactly what we're seeing maybe
maybe there was potential for knight c3 first but
instead it takes back on d5 that was the
first one i said bishop can go back to g2
and now the light square bishop is better than
knight so that's the problem for black in these
type of positions it's not that white is much
better but why is a little pull no matter the
trades that we get if we take on uh c three
minus knight gets there i have a slight pole
thanks to the quality of my bishop on g2 and now
if i go knight d5 this could be a slightly better
um bishop of opposite color intense queen and
rook's middle game because the problem on f7
is greater than any problem that white has
but black is still holding in all these lines
i think you have to try 95 though and
they're the sirens i know there they go um
it's not for any player's chances here looks
pretty fine so far hey car looking like he's
having to time his life cracking
up i don't know what that's about
so a car is having a blast and vidit seems to
be really laser focused on the center of the
board here and i guess that's what it was about
he decides to trade one pair of rooks and this
rook would love to get to c6 and start trying
to get in the position but bishop c5 now says
nope no progress for you and the pawn can be e4 to
reinforce his bishop to keep it solidly in place
but we play e4 black could play f5 and say hey my
bishop is now open up as well so i think this game
in all likelihood will be a draw
i think they'll split the point
i'm not quite sure how white intends
to improve the position from this point
f7 is defended queen defends
b6 you can play bishop e7 or d8
you can play e4 and check the queen to f3 check
i don't see what did it could possibly
do here i think it's totally fine
so bishop e7 allows for work to d8 next
and swapping the rooks results in immediate
quality uh rookie 6 or d6 as well
nice and if rook d7 you play with e7
if rookie 6 or d6 you can try to do that
rookie 6 rook d7 there still is rook d6
because you can take on f7 with check but i can
take you back because once this rook gets to d6
it's a problem down the d file so i
dropped the rook on the square it means to
play bishop e7 going for the rook swap
next move and i think we'll see a draw
green
i'm doing well thank you for asking see you i
see you on the chat thanks for everybody who's
tuned in right now we just have two games to go
this one uh and if we get a winner in the next
one then it's all over before we go to a bullet
tiebreaker and the first to win a bullet game
wins the match so vidit is trying to
pretend like he has something here
but it's a whole lot of nothing the queen and the
bishop doing a great job of covering these pawns
aren't dark squares which means the bishop one c4
can't get there okay these pieces all under attack
but so what how can you make progress here maybe
f4 at some point doesn't look real plays it
and this queen can probably continue
to go back and forth from e7 to c7 so
h4 takes do not take with the queen that's how you
drop a pawn and that could be a problem even there
actually isn't so bad the nature of the opposite
colored bishops should be totally fine for black
sticks with bishop of course
and now white is up a pawn
so he's pretending hey i've got
the extra pawn all is good here
but the queen's still coming to e7 and maybe into
f6 that pawn moves the queen can come into g5
yeah this is nothing hold on nothing and
i wonder if icaru could start thinking
about playing for a win because
he is well ahead in the clock and
you know if at a certain point you realize
hey i can't really lose so why don't i
play on and try to see if i can swindle one
wouldn't be that surprised like queen f5 here
trying to get over to c2 perhaps e4 not an easy
move to play when you give up more of the dark
squares or queen f3 queen c2 check king f1 yeah
it's a draw both players know that it's a draw
but no harm in trying to just steal a victory
and no he'll trade him enough to now i think
yeah he realizes there's
nothing here and draw agreed
okay so game two now if there's a winner the
match is over if they draw their game we get
a bullet game to decide this we're getting oh
is he taking him to bullet he card did this
on purpose he wants bullet and you could see him
trying to hold back a smile and vidit's like oh no
oh no oh no here we go here
here's the the draw that
everybody has seen many times car did this against
magnus if he feels like it favors him to get rid
of this game he's going to do it and it does favor
him because we get the bullet so for video gujrati
he can enjoy his couple rating points that he
earned from this draw but he's probably not
thrilled about entering the bullet and you see
him taking a deep breath there stretching the neck
it all comes down to this bullet game unless
they draw in which case we get more bullet
here comes the 1-0 all right visit
with the black pieces will we see
a car go for e4 oh what just happened
okay i guess car wasn't ready and does vinnie get
the white pieces because he was the higher seed
right wasn't it car visited the three seed
and no if it was a seven seat ah okay never
mind but it was a seventy the car was a four
seat uh so he car gets choice that makes sense
for some reason my head bit it was the three
seat because they all tied first to eighth
place with eight and a half out of ten but i i
was remembering incorrectly i think i thought
that mama jarva was the two and then but it was
a three but that was definitely not the case okay
and the game has started hit car plus e4 we have
are we getting the berlin i doubt it no we get
this ansi delayed exchange uh spanish here and
anthony berlin and vinnie needs to move quickly
he needs to move well of course but he needs to
move quickly and i think that's going to be his
biggest problem right now his car is going to use
time as a weapon and knight g5 doesn't have to do
anything this is protected you just take back
and what's the situation whoa hung up on did
it went upon the center that was huge and vivid
needs to fight quickly because he is up a clean
pawn right now and he brings queen back to e6
he wants to play f6 to keep his f5 no he's going
aggressive here and vin is actually ahead in the
clock wow the car blundered the e4 pawn and now
can you play e4 can you just push
that through no he doesn't do it
i'm wondering when e4 is possible but he this
g pawn is hanging in many variations because
a5 which both allows to play a4 and gives his
king an outlet and now with g5 he's playing on
both sides of the board here okay and he car is
even on the clock so when is e4 going to happen
the queen can be exchanged on d5 but that
fixes that is pawn structure as we enter the
uh late middle game stages do not take on f4
that blunders they broke on e6 but vince is
using too much time and his position is great
but i don't like his clock management right now
e4 what's this this knight's not hanging knight
c4 what's going on here queen takes f4 is there
some kind of e takes d3 because the back rank mate
no the queen covers on g1 so he brings queen back
to c7 he just does not not have enough time i
don't think he's going to be really trying to
save this one but his clock is not good no
no no no no his clock is really bad for him
yeah there's gonna be a win for
a car i feel like oh wait d2
what just happened there and now it's hikaru
taking d2 next but don't take this away because
queen takes d1 so he takes this one he's queen g1
that is precision by hikaru and he's going to win
on the board he wins on the clock hikaru nakamura
takes this speed chess championship grand prix
it was a blunder in the early stages too did
it stole the pawn and akaru just said yeah
okay i blundered it happens right down the
center here the uh queen is behind the pawn
so you can't take it back and still won the
game so what a performance by akari nakamura
even when it looks like he's in trouble we're
going to take a our last break and when we return
we'll bring his car on get a quick interview
with the speed chess championship grand prix
winner
and we are back with the speed
chest champion grand prix winner
hicary nakamura so i have to congratulate you
first and foremost for qualifying for the speed
chess championship aren't you proud of yourself
one second i apparently have to mute my zoom
yeah okay can you hear me now
i can hear you can you hear me
nope can't hear me all right nikaru way
way i'm doing something wrong one second um
wait wait no no one side one one second robert
let me let me go back the other way sorry
no no worries um okay can you hear me i
can hear you the whole time can you hear
me this is the last one i'm trying this
let me let me reopen this sorry look um
now i'm muted in zoom 2. uh-oh can you hear me
though no yeah now i hear yes sorry okay so now
i think it's fine no i think i have to mute like
the streamer figure out which one is muted um and
so forth but yeah i think we're good now so gotcha
all right go ahead go ahead i was congratulating
you on as a joke for qualifying for the speed
chess championship because you did win the speech
champion grand prix like the total series you just
you're a monster like you just nobody can stop you
how do you do it um you know i i mean i think
in general uh i i i think in general um mainly
what i would say is that you just play every
game you take it one game at a time basically
okay well how about the your decision in the final
you made that quick draw which you've done before
when you think it optimizes your winning chances
against vidit you just said let's make a draw and
head to bullet so that looked like a little bit of
foresight by you yeah i mean i think the thing is
is that i felt against probably against veda and
parham specifically they're two of the best blitz
players like who i could play against and um and
so if i have the opportunity to go into bullet i
probably should be a bigger favorite
there than i'm going to be in being blitz
right and you certainly prove that to be the case
and when you drop that pawn against evin there
were you concerned about the result or did you
feel like you would be able to bounce back because
that was a pretty important pawn objectively in
the position yeah i mean i think at that point i
was i was a little bit discombobulated everything
was kind of going weird because i tried to run an
ad and then like they started the game right away
then there was on board then i tried to make a
move and the game started like five seconds later
it's all pretty pretty random but i think again
in bullet more so than blitz you just you just
make moves and i felt that um actually the game
against vedic wasn't the one that i thought was
close i think the game against parham was the one
um where he thought for too long there was this
critical moment in the middle game where i think
he used like 20 seconds or 15 15 to 20 seconds
for two moves and that was the game where he was
up on time and it's very very complicated and
i think that one was objectively a little bit
closer and tighter than the one against vedic i
just kept making moves against vida and he just
couldn't keep up with the flow yeah and obviously
both of them are very strong players but so how
do you train that like how do you force yourself
to make a move you're just an example of it was
complicated he was a little ahead in time but then
he spent 20 seconds so how can you force yourself
to play a good move quickly rather than
try to find the absolute best move i mean
it's bullet chests time is money as the saying
goes and um you just try to move quickly and i
i think in general um like the one good thing
about position against vita especially was that
the the way the position was i didn't really
have many things to consider i had to try to
like maneuver my knight to c4 or play like f4 when
he tries g4 h4 on the king's side and so the fact
that i didn't really have many moves to consider
i think really helped me in terms of just just
playing moves because there isn't much to do i'm
down a pawn and much worse but you just make moves
and hopefully your opponent isn't as fast or they
make some mistakes and and vida uh he just wasn't
wasn't quite fast enough at the end there yeah
and hikara throughout the speeches champions grand
prix you want five knockout brackets so pretty
impressive there did you keep track or did you
is that a surprise to you no i didn't keep
track i mean the thing is most of the ones
that i played in i felt were at least two of them
were very random where i got to a bad start i had
to win like four or five in a row at the end to to
get into the um to get into in into the knockout
so i knew i had won quite a few i didn't really
pay close attention to it though so um you know
you just play and i i felt that i feel like in
the head-to-head especially to format a bullet
at the end um generally speaking i should be the
favorite against probably anybody and i think i
kind of proved that um based on how many of the
knockouts i won okay my final question for you
is now we know four more players who are taking
part in the speed chess championship based on
their grand prix standings and those are artemiev
nerdy because parham maxwell and hayek martirosian
of well i think you're going to say our 10 minutes
i'll exclude him for the time being which of those
players has the best chance of registering
an upset in the speedchest championship
i mean you say upset i'm i'm not sure that i would
say our tamiya is an underdog that's why that's
why i took him out of the equation i i would
also make the argument i'm not honestly sure that
parham is an underdog either out of those four
guys um so yeah i guess what i would say is in
general um those first two i don't think are gonna
be really be underdogs i think probably notre beck
is is the one who's most likely to cause an upset
um though out of that group of four because i
consider par ham and artemia to be at least even
if not favorites when they who whomever they uh go
up against the speech house championship so even
if they're playing somebody like mvl or wesley you
say that they're about level toss-up i i mean
i think parham and and um parham and vladislav
the other but they're both very strong players i
think it's close they might be slight underdogs
but they're not going to be big underdogs okay now
that's you know some high praise we know from our
tamil he's made the semi-finals before that's no
surprise but i guess uh by feed a classical rating
it's a different story than when you get to the
online especially these quicker time controls so
he carved you know gotta thank you for joining us
the interview and congratulate you once more you
are the champion of the speeches championship
grand prix you're the reigning speeches
champion so a lot of titles to bestow upon
you and we're very appreciative of your time
yeah thank you that's fun all right and
there you have it the final standings of the
speed chest champion grand prix hikaru nakamura
finishes in a dominant first 137.5 points he made
just as many points from the knockout bonus as he
did from the swiss score and that's the difference
look at that i mean you have the players right
after him or temeo ferocious abuse and parham
maxoudlu they all scored almost as much as hikar
did as their swiss base score but it was where
in the knockout where hikaru was just an absolute
monster winning five of them and that's where his
bonuses came from and artemyev he qualifies
feroceae has already made his way through by
virtue of finishing second place in the speeches
championship super swiss sorry kara won that
ferocious gets the second spot and that allows
heike marchi roshan to sneak in as the fourth
qualifier from the grand prix in addition to nerdy
back abductor and parham magsudu and reminded
everybody that there will be more qualification
spot on the line there's one in the speed chess
invitational which will be happening in the near
future you should you know follow chess.com social
media to find out when that will be follow the
news reports but it has not yet been confirmed as
the date but 1250 first place prize as well as the
qualifications speech chess championship and how
else could you get the speeches championship most
of the spots are away the top four from the grand
prix the winner of the uh super swiss which ended
up being fedor save in second nihal sarin from the
jfcc and that leaves one spot up for qualification
grabs in the speedchest championship invitational
on that note the grand prix has come to a
conclusion it's been a really fun series of events
hikaru nakamura week in week out no matter who he
faces no matter if he drops an early game or not
he finds his way to the top and he is a worthy
champion we gotta give all the credit in the world
to karna nakamura it's a bit of gujarati today
for making it such a fun fight making it to the
bullet tiebreaker where did it stole upon but just
couldn't keep up on the clock until karu won it
and that's all from chess.com for this speech
of champion grand prix i'm grandmaster robert